Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
So some of you long-time viewers are likely at this point,
familiar with my obsession with sleep.
Well, a huge reason for this
is due in no small part to today's guest.
An amazing human and one of the world's leading researchers
in the field of sleep science.
His name is Matthew Walker.
He's a former professor of psychiatry
at Harvard medical school
and a current professor of neuroscience and psychology
at UC Berkeley, where he also serves as founder and director
of the center for human sleep science.
His book, "Why We Sleep"
is an international smash bestseller.
It's an extraordinary evidence-based primer
on all facets of sleep.
It's a read that personally has profoundly impacted me.
And I say this without any hyperbole, a must
for anyone and everyone looking to live and feel better.
Matthew is somebody I've wanted to have on the show
for ages and ages.
I'm over the moon that he's here today.
And this conversation might be long, it's three hours long,
but fear not it is utterly, utterly fascinating,
essential listening, profound, life altering
and everything I hoped it would be.
So please hit that subscribe button if you haven't already,
thank you and strap in.
This is me and Dr. Matthew Walker.
Well, Matthew, so delighted to have you here.
People who listen or watch this show, know well,
my level of obsession with sleep,
I'm gonna try to refrain from making it
basically an indulgent referendum on my sleep-
(indistinct) That's great as well.
I'm sure I will diverge
into that at some point, 'cause I think it's instructive,
but I've been looking forward to this for a very long time.
A huge fan of the work that you do and it's just a pleasure
and an honor to have you here today.
Well, it's a privilege and a delight
to be sitting across from you-
Thank you.
I'm a longtime listener as well.
Cool, thank you.
So thank you for what you do.
Yeah, absolutely.
One of the,
I wanna kick off with this.
One of the super interesting hypotheses in the book is this,
that you purport is this idea that sleep evolved
before the brain hands before wakefulness.
So the lens through which we think about sleep
is sort of in reverse, right?
The question shouldn't be, why do we sleep?
The question is really why are we awake?
And whether or not that's true,
I think it's super interesting and instructive
to kind of shift that lens.
And when you think about it, from that perspective,
everything seems a little bit different.
Yeah, it isn't and I have no good sound evidence
for that theory right now.
But I think from an evolutionary perspective,
the first thing which perplexes me is the idiocy of sleep.
When you think of sleep an evolutionary perspective,
firstly, you're not finding a mate, you're not reproducing.
You're not caring for your young.
You're not foraging for food and worst of all,
your vulnerable to predation.
So--
Not only that, you're an insane person.
You go through this whole thing,
like if you were awake and you were experiencing the states
that you experienced when you're asleep,
you would be institutionalized.
That's right. Yeah.
And that's what we call dream sleep,
which is, seems to be normal.
But you know, on any one of those grounds,
sleep should have been strongly selected against
in the course of evolution.
But the fact that sleep has fought its way through,
along every step of the evolutionary pathway.
In fact, if we look back,
we can even find sleep like states in earthworms,
which are ancient from an evolutionary perspective.
So in other words,
sleep evolved with life itself on this planet.
And then despite all of those trappings,
it fought its way through heroically,
every step along the evolutionary pathway.
In other words, if sleep doesn't serve
some absolutely vital set of functions,
it's probably the biggest mistake
that the evolutionary processes has ever made.
And we've now realized
that it didn't make a spectacular (indistinct)
but that premise, that sleep evolved is usually founded
on the idea that we were awake.
And then we evolved to sleep.
And one thought that crossed my mind
and I was perhaps stupid enough to write it in the book was,
I wonder if it's the other way around,
why don't we assume that we evolved sleep?
Why don't we assume that sleep is the defacto state
of all birth life on planet earth?
And it's from sleep that wakefulness emerged and evolved.
Now, shy of a time capsule or some serious smelling salts,
I'm probably not gonna be able to go back
and figure that out.
But I think it's an interesting sort of way to-
Well, the evolutionary advantage of wakefulness
is self-evident.
We need to procreate, we need to feed ourselves.
But less obvious is the evolutionary advantage of sleep.
It just strikes us as being something that gets in the way
as opposed to crucial for all the functions
that you kind of go through (indistinct) in the book.
And I think that's perhaps one of the reasons that people
are so misunderstanding of sleep
and so understandably neglecting of sleep,
because most people, if you didn't understand what sleep is,
you would think, well,
my body gets some rest and my mind is dormant
and nothing could be further from the truth.
There is an immense cascade of health benefits.
This constellation of night time gifts
that sleep will provide to your body.
And every operation of the mind that we know
is overhauled some spectacular things.
In fact, during certain stages of sleep,
your brain is up to 30% more active than when you're awake.
And so it's so understanding that we would think, well,
you know, if I didn't know anything about sleep,
surely I can just shave off an hour here or two.
And it just doesn't work like that.
You know, one hour we can think of
this incredible global experiment
that's performed on well over 60 billion people
across seven to sorry,
well over 2 billion people across 70 countries twice a year,
it's called daylight savings time.
And what we've discovered is that in the Spring,
when we lose just one hour of sleep,
there is a 24% increase in heart attacks the following day.
So crazy.
Yet in the Fall-
and then the reverse
in the Fall.
Yeah, exactly.
You sort of see, I think it's a 21% reduction
in heart attacks, so that's how fragile.
And yet if everybody was sleeping eight hours a night,
it would be irrelevant.
So it's less about daylight savings time
than it is about our social constructs
around when we need to get up and go to work
or go to school.
That's, right.
Yeah. I think, you know, society,
has firstly stigmatized sleep with this label of laziness
that, you know, if you're getting sufficient sleep,
your maybe slothful.
And sometimes when I'm at speaking events,
people will come up and they'll usually
wait right until the end of the line of questions.
And they'll whisper sort of to me,
look, I'm one of those people who needs, gosh,
probably about eight hours of sleep.
And you know, as it, this, the worst secret,
the worst than a shameful thing that you could ever suggest.
So I think that's the first issue,
but then we're working long hours and pre-pandemic,
you know, commuting times had also increased.
And when you think about that,
so we're leaving the house earlier.
We're arriving home later,
nobody wants to short change on time with family off
Netflix or whatever it is.
And so the one thing that gets squeezed like vice grips
in the middle of the night is this thing called
a full night of sleep.
Yeah, you're almost some kind of punk rock revolutionary.
You protect your sleep time, right?
It is the one thing that's negotiable or dispensable
when you're looking at how you allocate your time.
That's right, it seems to be.
And the, of course the reality is that sleep alas
is not an optional lifestyle luxury,
it's a non-negotiable biological necessity.
It is your life support system.
We all know that the people who say
I only need four hours or I only I'm fine on five hours.
And I think you have,
I've heard you say something along the lines of 0% of people
need less than X number of hours.
Like that's all a story people tell themselves.
But it's simply not the case.
That's right. Yeah.
So I think if you look at the weight of the evidence,
the number of people who can survive on five hours of sleep
or less without showing any impairment
rounded to a whole number
and expressed as a percent of the population is zero.
And it's, to me, you would ask the question,
well, why do people think that they're doing okay?
And what we've discovered is that your subjective sense
of how well you're doing when you are insufficiently slept
is a miserable predictor of objectively,
how you're doing when you're insufficiently slept.
And so, it's a little bit like a drunk driver to bar,
they've had six or seven shots
and they pick up their car keys and they say, look,
I'm fine to drive home.
And your response is,
I know that you think you'll find to drive home,
but trust me objectively, you're in no state.
And it's the same way with a lack of sleep.
So that's one of the,
the sort of the flattening aspects of insufficient sleep
that you think you're doing just fine.
And gradually over time,
that deficient form of you becomes the new norm.
And most people don't go from sleeping eight hours
down to five hours.
It's this sort of gradual chipping away at the sleep time.
And they don't realize the version of themselves.
And a great example of this clinically
is in sleep disorders, such as sleep apnea.
And these patients will say to you,
look doc, I think I'm fine, I think I'm doing pretty well.
And then you treat the sleep apnea
so they start sleeping better than not snoring.
They're not gasping for breath.
And within a few weeks they cannot believe
the transformed state of themselves.
And I had one patient who said, you know,
it was as though with the sleep apnea device,
I'd come along and I'd wiped a frosted window clear
and finally I could see again.
And that's the type of mental benefit that you get
and of course physiologically, it's amazing.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I just know, you know,
when you're younger sleep comes easy, as you start to age,
it becomes a little bit more fragile and elusive.
And I found myself having to really be much more intentional
about it
and the difference between having a good night's sleep
where I get my eight hours
and I know that I've been in a sufficient amount of,
of REM state and REM deep state all of that,
my whole experience of my life is completely different
from those nights where I struggle and wake up
and had maybe six and just not so good,
like everything from, mentally, emotionally,
physically product productivity wise,
like every single,
there is nothing that is not positively impacted
by having a really good night of sleep.
And yet it's for me,
we'll get into this later,
but you replicating that day in day out, becomes tricky.
Yeah. And it is a hard thing, you know,
and I think one of the lessons I learned
from publishing the book, you know, at the time,
I think the book came out in 2017
and it took about four years to write.
So prior to that sleep was really the neglected stepsister
in the health conversation of today.
And I was so,
I was so upset by the suffering
that was happening in society
caused by this global sleep loss epidemic.
And as a consequence, you know,
I was almost a little bit heavy handed,
I think in sort of dishing out some of these facts.
And I have to be honest,
I have to speak the truth of the science as well.
But for certain people that almost made them
sort of more anxious, particularly for people with insomnia,
who of course would come to a book called "Why We Sleep,"
but the book wasn't called how to cure your insomnia.
But I'm sure, of course, they're still gonna buy that book.
And I think I was, I learned my lesson
to offer some kind of preface regarding that,
that, this book is gonna be very triggering and challenging
if you don't sleep well.
And therefore,
when you're not Daisy chaining those nights of good sleep
just as you're describing night after the night,
and you understand the detriments of sleep,
it can be concerning.
And I'm the worst for that.
You know, just like you, I can't string it together.
Now, I'm getting older,
I'm well in the foothills of middle age.
You (indistinct) fabulous by the way.
Thank you, I just turned 70 the other days
so it's great.
But you know, I think it's that I feel that anxiety
and for me, it's terrible because I'm lying in bed awake.
I'm realizing that, you know,
my dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex is not shutting down.
I'm not releasing this newer chemical.
My cardiovascular system is going to be this,
my immune system,
and at that point,
you're dead in the water
for the next two hours.
You have no chance.
So you become the sort of like the-
And you're the guy,
like, I'm the guy who's supposed to have this figured out.
Yeah, that's right.
And that just shows you that, you know,
even if you have, you know, all of this knowledge, you know,
biology can still teach you a few lessons.
Well, there's so many directions I wanna take this,
but I think it probably would be wise
to just spend a few minutes talking about what, like,
sort of defining our terms,
like what is sleep, like going through the various stages
and kind of explaining the terrain.
Yeah. So sleep in humans, at least,
and most mammals and birds
is broadly separated into two main types
that you'd mentioned.
On the one hand we have Non-Rapid Eye Movement sleep
or Non-REM sleep for short.
And Non-REM sleep has been further subdivided
into four separate stages, in fact,
unimaginatively called stages one through four,
we're a creative bunch clearly are sleep researchers.
Decreasing in the depth of sleep.
So stages three and four
are those really deep stages of restorative sleep.
That's what your sort of sleep tracker would say,
that's deep sleep stages, one and two, the light sleep.
And then on the other hand,
we have rapid eye movement sleep or REM sleep.
Named not after the popular Michael Stipe band
for the 1980s.
But after these strange horizontal shuttling eye movements
that occur under the eyelid, as you're in this stage.
And REM sleep is the stage during which we principally dream
and that's where you have your most sort of florid,
most narrative hallucinogenic, emotional sort of dreams.
And it turns out that those two types of sleep,
Non-REM and REM will play out in this incredible battle
for brain domination throughout the night.
And that sort of cerebral war is going to be won and lost
every 90 minutes and then replayed every 90 minutes,
at least in humans.
And that creates the standard cycling architecture of sleep.
What's fascinating though
and we actually still don't quite understand why,
is that the ratio balance of those two types of sleep,
Non-REM and REM, changes across the night.
And what I mean by that is in the first half of the night,
the majority of those 90 minute cycles
are comprised of lots of deep Non-REM sleep,
but very little REM sleep.
And so as you push through to the second half of the night,
now that seesaw balance will actually shift.
And instead you get much more rapid eye movement sleep,
particularly in the last couple of hours.
And it's not just important
to sort of understand one's sleep,
but understanding that structure has implications real life.
So let's say for example,
that I normally get my eight hours sort of,
and it doesn't, you know,
we can speak about timing on the clock face
and what makes sense for people.
But let's say that I'm a guy who goes to bed at 10:00
and I typically wake up at 06:00,
but today I've got an early morning meeting
or I want to sort of cut my sleep short
to get a jumpstart on the day to get to the gym.
And I wake up two hours early.
So I wake up at 04:00 rather than 06:00,
how much sleep have I lost?
Well, I've lost two hours from eight hours.
So I've lost 25% of my sleep.
Well, yes and no.
Yes, I've lost 25% of my total sleep,
but because REM sleep comes late in the morning,
I may have lost 50, 60,
maybe even 70% of all of my REM sleep.
So it's not just sort of, you know, academic to understand,
even though it's fun for me, but for many people,
it does have real world implications.
The complexity of it is fascinating.
I mean, sleep really is right up there, outer space
and the depths of the ocean in terms of its, its,
its mysteries
and the idea that we're just beginning to learn,
what's actually going on and it's not a matter of,
I'm sure you get this question all the time.
Like, what's more important, REM sleep or Non-REM sleep
or what's the sort of significance
of being deprived of one over the other,
but it's really the interplay of all of these things.
And the more complex you realize it to be,
it becomes impossible to consider that it's not crucial
to all facets of human health.
That's right.
And when we go back to that evolutionary story of,
of how detrimental sleep is as a state,
and it is, let's face it.
if there were any stage of sleep that were not important,
that mother nature could have come in and excised
and had you,
you know, doing all of these benefits of wakefulness
that can disrupt,
I'm quite sure she would have.
And what we've learned is that every stage of sleep
is important,
different stages of sleep,
perform different functions for the brain and body
at different times of night.
And so, yeah, I often get that question
where people will say, how can I get more deep sleep,
or how can I get more REM sleep?
And, you know, I often say, well,
why do you want more of that?
And they say, well, isn't that the good stuff?
And that they're both absolutely critical.
Now I could make a scientific argument
that REM sleep could be a little bit more important
from a simple mortality state,
because there were studies done back in the 1980s with rats,
and they've actually never been replicated again,
that I found them difficult to read.
I do research in, in humans, I don't do animal research,
and I think they won't be replicated for good reason.
What they wanted to do is see if a lack of sleep
is definitely, is a lack of sleep fatal.
And they had three different flavors of the experiment.
In the first,
they took rats and they just deprived them of sleep,
you know, night and day after day, night and day after day.
And what they found is that those rats died
within about 20 days.
So in other words,
rats will die as quickly from a lack of food
as they will from a lack of sleep.
That's how fundamental it is.
Then the two additional flavors of they experiment.
They selectively deprive them of either
just rapid eye movement sleep
so that they could get just Non-REM
or they did the opposite.
They just deprived them off Non-REM and gave them REM.
And firstly, both of those were fatal.
But what was interesting is that the rats died
from REM sleep deprivation within about 30 to 40 days.
And they died from deep Non-REM sleep deprivation
within about 50 or 60 days.
So if we want to sort of do a Coke, Pepsi challenge
between sort of, you know, Non-REM and REM,
which one wins out in the mortality battle,
it seems to be REM sleep.
And to me, that's interesting too.
If you'd asked me where I would place my bets,
I would have said Non-REM
the reason is because Non-REM came first.
If you look during the sort of the time course of evolution
of across phylogeny,
Non-REM sleep was the first sleep to emerge.
And it was only when we went from reptiles,
amphibians and fish
and then there was that bifurcation to birds
and then mammals did the evolution of REM sleep emerge.
So REM sleep is the new kid on the evolutionary block.
And furthermore REM sleep evolved twice independently
in birds and mammals, which I find is fascinating too.
So to come back to your point, I'm sorry, I'm drifting,
but all stages of sleep are critical.
No one stage of sleep you can do
without suffering detriment.
Right.
It is fascinating that sleep deprivation is fatal.
And you talked about this in the book.
There used to be before they were outlawed.
These contests people would see
how long they could go without sleep.
And there's one case study that I recall from the book
where the guy went mad and then literally,
I don't know how long it took him
like 10 days or something like that before he passed away.
Eight.
Well, there were two things that firstly you're right,
that there was, they used to Guinness,
The World Book of records used to recognize record,
attempts,
in sufficient sleep.
And then as the evidence mounted as to how deleterious
a lack of sleep is, they found it medically, you know,
impossible to recognize,
it ethically impossible to recognize.
So Guinness no longer recognizes any attempt
to break the world record for lack of sleep.
And, you know, to put that in context, we think of,
you know, Felix Baumgartner that incredible Austrian
who went up in the red bolts of space capsule as it were.
And when he ascended the outer atmosphere of the planet,
he opened up his door and he lapped out
and then he hurtled back down to earth
and I believe he broke the sound barrier with his own body.
Now Guinness says, that's fine,
but depriving yourself asleep, no, no, no.
So that's the relatives that have aspect
that we're thinking about.
There was a famous case of a radio disc jockey in New York
in the 1950s called Peter Tripp.
And he wanted to try and break the world record,
which was going eight days straight without sleep.
And he was doing this for the March of dimes.
And he would sort of sit in Times Square
and he was going to do this play, spin his records and,
after three days he was hallucinating and he was psychotic.
After five days,
he believed that people were trying to poison him
and that The Secret Service was coming to get him.
And then he did apparently break the world record.
He went eight days straight without sleep.
And then he slept for a little over 20 hours.
He woke up, he ordered his papers, had his breakfast
and people said, "Oh, it seems to be back to normal."
But Tripp was no longer Tripp after that,
he started to have problems at work.
He got caught up in what was called the payola scandal,
where people were sort of paying DJs under the desk
to play their tracks.
His marriage fell apart.
And the last people heard was that he was selling books
door to door in the Midwest.
And so you're attributing that to this crazy experiment
that he did.
Well, that that was the belief.
Now, other people I should note have gone past his level
of sleep deprivation.
And although they went through the same experience
during the lack of sleep psychosis, memory loss,
emotional instability, they seem to go back to normal.
So I think what's happening here
and I'm sure we'll come on
to sleep and mental health at some point,
in those people who are in that vulnerable range
where they're, they haven't crossed the threshold
of mental ill health, but they're right there
and anything that pushes them past it be a traumatic event,
be it a difficult divorce or a long stretch of no sleep
can actually pull that trigger
and send them over that sort of teetering precipice
down into a state of prolonged mental ill health.
That's wild.
But those are kind of fringe cases
in the sense that people are doing this wacky kind of thing.
But the more relatable prevalent situation is,
chronic sleep deprivation,
which I don't know what the statistics are, I'm sure you do,
of how many people just on a day in day out basis
are not getting enough sleep and how that plays out
long-term in terms of their physical, mental,
emotional health.
Yeah, it's quite shocking.
And I guess this is sort of the insomnia disclaimer,
if you've had to sort of listened away.
But firstly, what we know
is that one out of every three people
that you pass on the street
is not getting the sleep that they need.
So the CDC right now recommends stipulates
a minimum of seven hours of sleep to maintain human health.
And it doesn't, as you said,
most people are not pulling all nighters frequently
or trying to break world records, but it doesn't take that.
We've already mentioned the daylight savings experiment.
I'll just give you a few other examples.
If I take a healthy young male and I limit them
to let's say four or five hours of sleep
for a couple of nights,
their level of testosterone drops to someone
who is 10 years, their senior.
So a lack of sleep will age a man by a decade
in terms of that critical aspect of wellness and virility.
And we see equivalent impairments
in female reproductive health, by the way.
Follicular stimulating hormone,
abnormal menstrual cycles, difficulty in conceiving.
So that's hormones that go awry.
We also know for example,
that if I were to take you and put you on a diet
of let's just say four hours of sleep a night
for a couple of nights,
at the end of those four nights,
your blood sugar levels would be so disrupted
that your doctor would classify as being pre-diabetic.
That's crazy.
Which you know, stuns me
and to induce that kind of a deficit of 40% deficit
in your sort of glucose optimization,
you would have to gain about 20 pounds of obese mass
within four days where you could do it by under sleeping.
We also know for example that if you're not getting
sufficient sleep in the week before you get your flu shot,
you produce less than 50% of the normal antibody response.
I'm sure we'll discuss that when we speak about immunity.
There was an amazing experiment though done
by some colleagues in the United Kingdom
and they put healthy participants
through two different conditions.
In one condition, they will limited to six hours of sleep
a night for one week.
And then they were given a full eight hour opportunity
for one week.
And then they measured the change
in their gene activity profile
relative to when they were getting sufficient sleep.
And there were two striking findings.
The first was that a sizable insignificant 711 genes
were distorted in their activity
caused by that lack of sleep.
And this is not dramatic sleepless,
this is six of sleep a night.
I mean most people say,
six hours, I'm good, that's pretty good.
Right,
and that just doesn't seem to be the case biologically,
what was also interesting, however,
was that about half of those genes were actually increased
in their activity or what we call over expressed,
the other half would decreased
or switched off in their activity.
Now those genes that were suppressed
caused by a lack of sleep
when numerous genes associated with your immune system,
get those genes that were actually increased
in their activity with genes
that were associated with the promotion of tumors,
genes that were associated with cellular stress
and as consequence cardiovascular disease,
and genes that were associated also with metabolism
and changes in metabolism.
And what that study taught me at least,
is that there is no aspect of our physiology
that seems to be able to retreat
the sign of sleep deprivation and get away unscathed.
Yeah. One of the striking things in the book
that really hit me was,
the relative lack of elasticity in the human body.
In that just one night of dysregulated sleep a week
has much more of a profound deleterious effect
than you would think.
You would think like, well, I sleep pretty well most nights,
but you know, once a week, like my stuff got screwed up,
but you know, I'll recover.
But the downstream implications of just a little bit
of dysregulation are much more serious
than one would suspect.
Yeah. And I mean, a good example is,
another story where if you take a healthy adults
and you limit them to just four hours of sleep
for a single night,
the next day we see a 70% drop in critical anti-cancer
70%.
Fighting immune cells,
seven, zero called natural killer cells.
Now, today, you and I have both produced cancer cells
more than likely,
what prevents those cells from becoming and manifesting
as the condition that we call cancer
is impart these critical cancer-fighting immune cells,
natural killer cells,
that is a dramatic state of immune deficiency.
And it happens quickly after just one bad night of sleep.
So you could imagine the state of your immune system
after weeks, if not months of insufficiency.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually
already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is a Power plant meal planner,
our affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code, RRHealth at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people
for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com promo code RRHealth
for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Yeah, one of the things that is very vivid in the book,
as well as this is this process that takes place
when you're sleeping this kind of detoxification process.
Where you're kind of cleansing the brain and washing out
the beta amyloids and all that kind of negative things
that accumulate in the mind throughout the day,
because wakefulness is really the toxic state, right.
And sleep, that is the restorative state obviously.
And you likened it to the Island of Manhattan
where all the skyscrapers shrank
and like a wave washes over them and cleans all of them
and all this nasty stuff that we don't want is washed away.
And when you impede that process,
those things start to accumulate. Right?
And that's why we see so many of these downstream, you know,
diseases cropping up everything from Alzheimer's diabetes,
cardiovascular disease, et cetera.
Yeah. I mean, from the perspective of your brain,
this sounds a little bit extreme,
but biologically I think it's accurate that wakefulness
is low level brain damage and sleep is sanitary salvation.
And this I think is one of the most exciting areas
in sleep science over the past five years,
it's just ballooned.
And we've been fortunate enough to do some of this work,
which is the relationship between a lack of sleep
and Alzheimer's disease.
And it really is, has become a four-part story,
which is association causation, mechanism,
and then treatment hope.
So what we understood about four or five years ago
is that people who are typically sleeping
less than six hours a night,
went on to develop far more of those,
sticky toxic protein elements
that all the culprits underlying Alzheimer's disease
called beta amyloid and more recently,
this thing called tau protein.
They're the two proteins that we believe
underlie the condition of Alzheimer's disease.
Then what we also found is that people
who have sleep disorders
such as insomnia or sleep apnea
also have a significantly higher risk
of going on to develop Alzheimer's disease later in life.
But they're just associations they don't prove causality.
And then several years after that,
scientists demonstrated that if you take a healthy adult
and you deprive them of sleep for just one night
or you deprive them of just deep sleep for one night,
you see an immediate escalation in that Alzheimer's protein,
beta amyloid circulating in the bloodstream,
circulating the cerebral spinal fluid
and also within the brain itself
using brain imaging technology.
So that proved causality that you can take
an otherwise healthy person,
take away that thing called sleep
and you can trigger that instigation
of a what seems to be like the emergence
of an Alzheimer's cascade and pathology.
If that's true, then we ask the question,
well, what is it about sleep that deescalates,
that Alzheimer's disease protein in the brain.
And there was just, I mean, this is,
I think it's Nobel prize worthy,
but a researcher called Macon Nedergaard
at the university of Rochester
made three remarkable discoveries.
She was looking at mice and what happened when they slept.
And the first thing that she discovered is that the brain
has a cleansing system and we didn't think it did.
Now, we knew that the body had its own cleansing system,
which everyone will know about called the lymphatic system,
but we didn't think the brain did.
And she discovered, in fact,
it does have a cleansing system called the glymphatic system
named after the glial cells that make up this process.
And those live in between the brain cells, right?
That's right.
Glial is, sort of,
if you look at the Latin and Greek, sort of derivative,
the entomology is the glue,
because we used to think that they were just the cells
that kind of glued the actual brain cells,
well, there they're all brain cells technically,
but would glue the neurons together.
But they sort of outnumber your neurons by many fold
and they're critically performed lots of functions,
but they form this network, this sewage system.
So that was the first discovery.
Then she found that that cleansing system
wasn't always switched on in high flow volume
across the 24 hour period.
Instead it was when those mice were sleep.
And when they went into deep sleep,
that that sewage system really kicked into high gear.
The final discovery and that's what makes it relevant
to Alzheimer's disease
is that she found that one of the metabolic byproducts,
one of the pieces of metabolic detritus,
that that sleep was washing away
was this toxic protein of beta amyloid.
And just last year, scientists in Boston
actually found a very similar pulsing cleansing mechanism
in human beings.
So that was a mechanism that helped us realize
how would this could all connect together.
For me though, it may all sound very depressing
just as you mentioned for yourself and I experienced this,
the older that we get, typically the worse our sleep,
and the older that we get,
the greater our risk of Alzheimer's disease.
And so it may sound quite a depressing story,
but I think there's a silver lining here.
Because unlike many of the other factors
that are associated with aging and Alzheimer's disease,
for example, changes in the physical structure of the brain,
or even changes in the blood flow dynamics of the brain
they're fiendishly difficult to treat.
And in medicine, we have no good wholesale approaches.
But that sleep is a missing piece in the explanatory puzzle
of aging in Alzheimer's disease,
is exciting because maybe we can do something about it.
Perhaps what we could do is in mid-life,
which is when we start to see the decline of deep sleep,
that's when we could intervene with optimization of sleep,
with lots of different methods that are being developed.
And in that way,
could we bend the arrow of Alzheimer's disease risk
down on itself?
Could we shift from a model of what we have right now,
which is late stage treatment to mid-life prevention?
Going from a model of sick care to actually healthcare.
That's one of our sort of moonshot goals.
I'm incredibly excited.
I mean, that's the Holy grail, right?
Yeah.
And I think about this all the time when I wake up
after an amazing night of sleep
and then my experience throughout the day is optimal.
And then the following night,
I have a degraded version of that and I wake up and I think,
why can't we figure out a way to replicate this,
day in and day out without pharmaceutical intervention,
like I'm trying to do all the right things
and yet it is so elusive.
And part of that yes is age because when you're a teenager,
you can just, fall asleep in an instant
and seem to get a good night's sleep, no matter what,
but I'm constantly thinking about like,
how do you figure this out and master it,
because if you could,
it would literally change everybody's lives.
And, you know, if you take the reverse of that, we know,
starting with this recommended sweet spot
of between seven to nine hours a night,
going in the downward direction there's a very simple truth,
which is that the shorter your sleep, the shorter your life.
Short sleep predicts or cause mortality.
Which is so ironic given that, the hustle culture,
it's all about maximizing those daylight hours
and I'll sleep when I'm dead.
I'm just harkening that death.
It's mortally unwise advice, anyone who tells you that.
But to me, I think, you know, sleep,
sleep could be seen as the Swiss army knife of health.
Whatever ailment that you're facing
sleep normally has a tool in the box that can help.
And so for me, I think the Shangri-La
is perhaps less about trying to elongate lifespan,
sorry, lifespan, sorry,
than it is really about prolonging people's health span
because when you ask most people,
that's what they really want
when they're trying to sort of, you know,
live a clean, healthy lifestyle, a lifestyle.
They don't want a life with disease and sickness,
but when you are starting to short change your brain
and your body of sleep, that's what you're inviting.
And the elastic band of sleep deprivation
will stretch only so far before it snaps.
And if you fight biology, normally you lose.
And the way you know you've lost is disease and sickness.
The human hubris over all of this though,
is something to behold
because we always think we can find
an end run around these things.
And as beautiful and magnificent as the scientific method is
it tends to be very binary in its approach.
So if X then Y controlling for variables,
but when you're dealing with systems that are so complex,
my sense is that oftentimes
it leads to unintended negative consequences, right?
Like take this pill and you'll sleep well,
but we're not realizing or looking at all these other things
that are occurring and it isn't until much later
when researchers like yourself can pull the covers on that
and say, this was not such a good idea.
Yeah, pull the covers, no pun intended.
Yeah, right, right, right.
But I think you're right.
There is a very understandable, again,
I don't want to sort of be finger wagging or chastise people
if you don't know the science of sleep, you know,
I would be just as unknowing,
but it took mother nature 3.6 million years
to put this essential thing called,
a seven to nine hour sleep need in place.
To think that with hubris or arrogance,
that we could come along and within five or 10 years,
if we're medical sort of forcing medical residents
to go through these ridiculous sort of schedule,
or if you're in some other professional industry
that you can just find a way
to hack that system is unfortunately miss founded.
The stuff that you said about Alzheimer's and dementia
makes a lot of sense,
but how does that work with cardiovascular disease?
I mean, obviously brain health is vascular health
and heart health, certainly his vascular health,
but what is the relationship between sleep, sleep quality
and taking an insurance policy out against heart disease?
Yeah, I mean,
so we mentioned that the daylight savings time example,
but more than that, we know that people
who are typically sleeping less than six hours a night
on average will have about a 200% increased risk
of cardiovascular disease or a heart attack
in the life's time.
We also know from a prospect of study
that came out of Harvard medical school,
that they took a large range of people
who had no preexisting signs of cardiovascular disease.
And then they track them across five or six years.
And what they found is that those people who are sleeping
less than six hours a night,
they had a 200 to 300% increased risk of calcification
of the coronary artery.
And the coronary artery is essentially that's the, you know,
the corridor of life for your heart.
When you hear people saying, gosh,
they had a massive coronary.
What they mean is that that coronary artery
had become blocked calcification
and that's exactly what we see.
Now, again, this was a prospect of city.
No one had any signs of that before,
but when you looked at that sleep shaving,
at sleep coming down and down,
that was the predictive factor.
We also know that, however,
it's sort of turning the tables in the positive.
Why does sleep give you that benefit.
During deep sleep, our heart rate decelerates,
our vascular system, our vessels start to relax.
You can think of deep sleep,
like the very best form of blood pressure medication
that you could ever wish for.
We also see that it's during that nighttime phase,
when we drop levels of cortisol,
which otherwise if left in high concentrations
to stress related chemical, it's an adaptive chemical too.
We all need cortisol.
But if you're just chronically high in cortisol,
that is, definitely for your cardiovascular system
and sleep will actually ratchet down that level.
Also sleep will quiet, the fight or flight branch
of your nervous system.
It's called the sympathetic nervous system,
which I think is terribly named,
it's anything but simple that in it's agitating,
it's aggravating and it's during deep sleep
that we actually shift over from that fight or flight branch
to the more quiescent calming branch
called the parasympathetic nervous system.
And so now we can start to understand why we see risks
for heart attack, risks for cardiovascular disorder.
We published a paper a couple of months ago,
demonstrating that short sleep
and in particularly not just short sleep,
but also fragmented sleep.
And this is I think another important point
that we've learned in the most recent years.
It's not just about the quantity of sleep.
It's also about the quality of that sleep.
And we found that people who had fragmented sleep
had a higher likelihood of their blood vessels
becoming hard.
It's what we call atherosclerotic sclerosis,
the hardening of the blood vessels,
which can then be a direct pathway to cardiovascular disease
and heart attack as well.
That's interesting.
And is there a sense of where that falls
in the pecking order of importance
when you compare it to nutrition or exercise
or these other kind of contributing or ameliorating factors
with respect to heart disease?
It's just as heavier hitter.
If you look at the combination of quantity and quality
of sleep and you look at the effect sizes, the, you know,
it's right up there.
You can almost play the game.
And I don't mean to do this because I'm someone who pays,
I'm very dedicated to a practice of physical activity
and exercise.
I'm not quite at your level, but,
and I very cleanly, I too I'm a vegetarian.
So I respect those things
because I know how utterly important they are
for my health span of my lifespan,
but I can do a thought experiment where I say,
I take you Rich Roll, and I'm going to deprive you
of either exercise for 24 hours of food for 24 hours,
of water for 24 hours or of sleep for 24 hours.
And sleep I--
No, there's no comparison.
By a country mile will dwarf the physiological
and mental deficits that come by way of that.
I think the only other thing that's perhaps
will overtake sleep is oxygen.
If I start your function, you will, you will-
Yeah me, me.
I hold my hands up,
I lose out to oxygen.
But you've said often that, you know,
when you think of the pillars of health,
sleep isn't a pillar,
it's the foundation upon which all these other pillars
are erected essentially, right?
Yeah.
That's the way
to think bout it.
I used to think
it was a third pillar but then,
the more I've done this research over the years,
the more I realized that I was wrong.
It is a foundation on which those, the two things sit,
I can give you a good example.
If you're trying to manage your weight
if you're trying to diet, let's say and lose weight,
but you're not getting sufficient sleep.
70% of all the weight that you lose
will come from lean muscle matte, mass, sorry
and not fat.
The body when it's fatigued in that way,
wants to hold onto those fats.
Exactly. Your body becomes stingy in giving up its fat.
So in other words, when you are under slept,
but you're trying to watch your diet, watch what you eat,
you will lose what you wanted to keep, which is muscle.
And you will gain what you wanna lose, which is fat.
Right. And on top of that,
that's when those crazy cravings for terrible foods happen.
I just know when I'm, when I'm under slept
that's when I start thinking about all these foods that,
you know, I shouldn't eat.
And it comes by way of two different routes
and then non-mutually exclusive one is a brain route
the other is a body route.
What we've firstly discovered
is that when you're not getting sufficient sleep, you know,
it be it six hours a night, five hours a night,
four hours a night for several nights,
there are two critical appetite regulating hormones
that go awry.
These hormones are called leptin and ghrelin.
Leapt, I sometimes joke that they sound like hobbits
but that's just my British Tolkien obsession.
But leptin is the hormone of satiety.
When you release leptin,
it says to your brain and your body,
you're full with what you've just eaten,
you don't wanna eat anymore, you're no longer hungry.
Ghrelin is the opposite. Ghrelin is the hunger hormone.
It says, no, no, no, you're not satisfied with your food
and you wanna eat more.
And when you are under slept,
those hormones go in the opposite direction
in ways you don't wish them to.
Firstly leptin, which is the satiety signal that drops away.
So you lose that signal of being full
and you constantly feel hungry.
If that weren't bad enough by itself,
ghrelin the hunger hormone that actually increases.
So now you may have eaten a standard meal
that normally otherwise would have been satisfying,
but it doesn't feel satisfying
and you still wanna eat more.
And on average people will typically eat
anywhere between two to 400 extra calories each day,
under these conditions of insufficient sleep.
What was also striking from these studies
is not just that you wanna eat more,
which in general you do, and you wanna snack more,
but it's what it is that you have a craving for.
Because when you are under slept,
you have this increase, particularly a dominant increase
in wanting to eat those heavy hitting carbohydrates,
also sugars, as well as salty snacks.
All of those are foods that we know in accessible,
put you on a path toward this obesogenic profile.
It would be interesting to take a look at,
whether or not the rate of people going to the drive-through
increases on daylight savings.
On that day, when everybody's lost an hour of sleep,
they're a little bit more tired.
I would suspect it would follow that a lot of people are,
you know, hitting McDonald's on the way to work.
I wish I could get that data.
I wish there was like a McDonald's app
where I could look at the usage statistics
and then do that sort of, you know, study.
So in the body, that's part of the reason,
but in the brain, there's also a pathway.
And we did a study several years ago,
where we took a group of healthy adults of normative weight
and we either gave them a full night of sleep
or we took sleep away for a night.
And then we put them and same individuals.
So it's the same people going through two different studies.
And inside of the brain scanner,
we were showing them these different food items
and they had to rate how desirable those food items were.
And we made this a little bit more real
by saying, look at the end of this brain scan,
we're gonna pull you out.
I'm going to give you one of those foods
so that you have to eat it.
So, you know, they're not just saying, "Oh, okay,
I should just be good and I know that,
that I should say is nice."
And, what we found firstly, is that people,
when they were under slept, their hunger increased,
firstly, sorry, that was firstly.
Secondly, what we found is that they were rating, you know,
junk foods as far more desirable as a consequence.
And then when we looked at the brain scan,
something fascinating happened,
the deep hedonic, emotional centers of the brain,
they were revved up as a consequence of a lack of sleep.
The sort of impulsive sort of, you know,
almost these addictive brain sensors.
In fact, they are a part of the same sensors
that go around in addiction.
What was also interesting is that other parts of the brain,
particularly a part right upstairs above your eyes
in the frontal lobe that had shut down,
which normally keeps all hedonic desires in check.
And as a consequence, the under slept people
were sort of no longer reaching for leafy greens
and a handful of nuts.
They were reaching for ice cream pizzas,
the salty snacks, et cetera.
So it's both within your brain.
That explains why, you know, for a fact, you know,
when I'm not sleeping, I'm just, I'm always hungry.
I can never get satisfied, I can never get full.
I don't know why it is, brain and body.
Well, I feel seen and heard
because as somebody who's been in recovery for a long time,
in an N of one experiment, I know when I'm under slept
or I've had a terrible night of sleep,
all of those kinds of addictive compulsion's,
because I have some self-awareness around them,
I'm able to like, understand that that's what's happening,
but it's always been confusing that it correlates,
like, why do I feel like acting out or eating this thing
or, you know,
like sending the email I shouldn't send
or all of these things that happen when I'm under slept.
That's very interesting.
Yeah. Thanks for bringing that up too
about addiction disorders.
We've done a little bit of work in this area, too.
What we found is that when we shortchange someone's sleep,
these dopamine centers within the brain that are
what we think of as reward based centers.
And they're the centers in the brain that addiction
will hijack.
Those become increased in their sensitivity.
So your reward sensitivity increases,
your risk taking increases, your impulsivity increases.
What we know is that those people who are under slept
are far more likely to develop
an addiction disorder during use,
we also know, and this is perhaps even stronger
of a relationship when you are trained to abstain
and go through recovery sleep is a huge predictive factor.
When you're getting enough sleep,
your chances of remitting and recovering are far higher
than when you're not getting sufficient sleep.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Well, this is a good opportunity for me to indulge you,
only own history here, because, you know,
just reading your book again, in getting ready for today,
I started thinking more profoundly and deeply
about my own history with sleep over the years.
And I just, I had this like dawning depressing epiphany
of just how sleep deprived I have been
up until like literally my late 30s
with how I've lived my life.
I mean, I, from age like 14 to 21,
I was a competitive swimmer.
I was waking up throughout junior high school
and high school at 04:45 every day
to go to swim practice for two hours, then I'd go to school,
then I'd go to some practice again for two more hours,
do my homework, go to bed, repeat,
chronically, sleep deprived through those years.
Going to college, the same thing.
And just, you know,
I have memories of just sleepwalking through my life,
just so exhausted, not just from the sleep deprivation,
but on top of that, like very rigorous training, right?
So I literally had no energy for anything.
And then around 21 is when my alcoholism
really started to kick in.
So then the next 15 years was a cycle,
a progressive cycle, of course, of, you know,
sleeping sort of drinking to black out, passing out,
going on three-day benders
and then experiencing those sleepless nights that occur
in the wake of that.
It would take three or four days normalize
and terrible nights of laying in bed,
sweating and staring at the ceiling and unable to sleep
and the shaking and the whole thing,
only to finally get,
by Wednesday getting one good night of sleep feeling okay.
And then repeating, repeating it again.
And I did that for 15 years and it wasn't,
I got sober at 31
and then I transferred a lot of my addictive tendencies
onto workaholism.
So it didn't get that much better, but looking back,
it's just unbelievable how much I shortchanged myself
from sleep.
And I think what is the relationship between
that early sleep deprivation and my alcoholism?
What is the relationship between
the alcoholic sleep deprivation
and my ability to be a functional human?
And all I can tell you is that when I look back,
I think back on those years,
I can barely remember a single book that I read.
I couldn't tell you anything that I learned in law school.
I barely remember college and my memory overall
is not so good.
It's really like unbelievable.
When I think about how profound that is
and the impact that it's had on my life.
On top of that, this is separate,
but I slept blocked like all the time when I was a kid.
I grew out of that, but I don't know how that plays into it.
But when you hear that, like, what what is your reaction?
Yeah, so I, you know,
firstly from the memory point that you mentioned,
we know that sleep is critical for letting in memory in,
in at least three different ways that we can speak about.
But what about the long-term consequences of that?
Well, we have a little bit of data
from the situation of airline pilots,
who typically,
have to undergo jet lag that chronically sleep deprived.
And firstly, what scientists found
when they looked at matching those pilots
with sort of someone of similar age,
some absurd background, education, lifestyle,
et cetera, et cetera.
They found that parts of the brain had actually shrunk.
It's what we call atrophy., they'd lost brain cells.
Where had they lost brain cells?
They'd lost them particularly
in the memory centers of the brain,
a structure that we call the hippocampus
and the hippocampus,
which sits on the left and the right side of your brains,
like a long cigar shape on the left and the right side.
It's almost like the informational inbox of your brain.
It's very good at receiving new information and memories
and holding onto them.
And that part of the brain had actually deteriorated
because of that disrupted sleep schedule.
Now you could argue,
well, perhaps it's just something about bias selection that,
I don't know how it would be,
but airline pilots they just--
(indistinct) Become pilots,
yeah, because of poor memory
they don't go into profession X,
they go into, now piloting is essential with memory.
And so I don't think that's the case,
but a better demonstration of that,
was then they looked at
how long that they'd been on the job.
How many years had they been going through that,
that sort of sleep deficiency.
And that predicted the magnitude of brain shrinkage,
which made me think, okay,
I think it's more likely
that it has to do with the sleep as well.
So is the a potential long-term organic atrophy consequence
of insufficient sleep on the brain.
We seem to think that there is yes.
But again, I think I want to be really careful here
and I don't want to be causing people alarm.
And what I would say is that it is never too late
to start sleeping better.
And that's not just me sort of pulling out the pom-poms
and trying to be positive. We've got data.
So in a series of studies and we've done a lot of work in,
as I mentioned in older adults.
But if you take a group of midlife adults
who are suffering from untreated sleep apnea, heavy snoring,
and then you put them on treatment,
which is called a CPAP machine,
C-P-A-P the Continuous Positive Airway Pressure.
And by the way, if anyone's listening to this
and they think that they suffer from a sleep apnea,
or they have a partner who does please go and get diagnosed,
it is a deathly disease untreated.
And what they found is that about half of those participants
complied to the treatment and about half didn't
and they track them over a 10-year period.
And what they found is that those individuals
who comply to the treatment
and who sleep was improved as a consequence,
they staved off the onslaught of Alzheimer's disease
and cognitive decline by anywhere between 10 to 15 years,
relative to those who remained untreated
or uncompliant with the treatment.
In other words, even in midlife, there is evidence to say,
it's never too late to start sleeping.
But can those brain centers that,
that have atrophied be regenerated
or is that a permanent thing?
We don't know.
And it depends on what extent of atrophy.
We do. We used to think maybe 30 years ago
that the brain didn't produce new brain cells
once it had matured and once you are an adult,
that was your sort of smorgasbord of brain cells.
And as you lost them through time
you never got them back.
(indistinct) When you drink,
you kill brain cells, they never come back.
They never come back.
Well, that's not true.
There are in many regions of the brain that is true,
but there are a couple of regions that it's not true.
And in fact, these memory centers, the hippocampus,
that's one of the centers that does actually
seem to have some degree of regenerative capacity.
How capable of meeting the demand of brain atrophy
and damage that that system is of regeneration is unclear.
What I should note by the way, is that that system of,
of the creation of new brain cells,
it's what we call neurogenesis,
which I think is a great alternative name for a band
rather than just Genesis, Phil.
If you deprive of sleep,
it fails to have the regulation of that neurogenesis.
You lose the capacity for neurogenesis
when you are under slept.
So it becomes this self-fulfilling negative vicious cycle
of prophecy that if you are not getting sufficient sleep,
those brain cells start to deteriorate and atrophy.
And then the one thing that could help you get them back
is the one thing that you keep depriving yourself of.
So you lose even the salvation of the,
the sort of the salvaging, sorry, I should say of that.
You mentioned pilots traveling
from time zone to time zone.
On top of that, I wanna talk about the medical profession.
'Cause here in, lie, the greatest irony,
these people who are dispatched with, you know,
tending to our health,
have this complete myopic perspective
when it comes to prioritizing sleep in their own profession.
And there's this systemic, you know,
kind of infrastructure set up that prioritizes
lack of sleep.
These residents who have to work these 30 hour shifts,
this legacy of an old tradition that was set in stone
long ago and continues like unbelievably to, you know,
be the standard operating procedure today,
which is unbelievable.
And I loved how you told the history of this,
this guy Halstead, right.
Who basically was a hard back in,
at the turn of the century and just said,
this is the way we're gonna do it.
And today we still do it in the manner
that he kind of established back then,
but it turns out he was like a raging cocaine addict.
That's right. Yeah.
So William Halsted was the guy who set up the resident,
the first resident training program in the United States
at Johns Hopkins University.
And, you know, it's called a residency for a reason
because you're going to become a resident.
You're going to live in the hospital.
And he was known for being able to go these heroic
long stretches without needing sleep.
And people were stunned.
And he expected his junior residents to match him in that.
And gradually after his death,
it emerged the reason why he was able to do that,
hosted in his early career
was actually studying the anesthetic properties of cocaine.
And unfortunately he started to use cocaine himself
and he became an accidental addict.
And that was how he was able to just go days straight,
without seemingly you know, needing sleep.
So--
Apparently
set the expectation that everybody else should be able
to match-
Should match.
The way that he was.
To go at the same degree.
Now, there were times there were stories where,
people would say, he would in the operating theater,
he would have to go and take a break
because he was saying he was not feeling well.
He was sweating a lot, he'd seemed be cold.
And he would have to go take a break. And, you know,
it's 'cause he was detoxing during along that surgery
so he had to go and administer again.
And there were even stories.
So he knew that he was an addict and he sought
to go into rehab under a different surname.
And at the time they were treating cocaine addiction
with morphine and unfortunately what happened
is that he came out of that rehabilitation program
with no resolution to his cocaine addiction,
but now he had a heroin addiction.
And the story goes that he would have his shirts,
his white shirts sent away
to get laundered in places like Paris (indistinct)
and they would come back both white and starchy,
but there would also be other, you know,
white related compounds in there.
And we've never let go of that (indistinct)
and I think inane practice,
and it's not medical residents who are at fault here,
you know, speak to any of them.
And none of them will tell you that
that's what I want to be doing.
And I've had conversations with a dear friend
called Pietra Tia, who went through the medical practices,
wonderful medical doctor.
And he describes, you know,
some shocking history with a lack of sleep.
And the statistics are just damning.
Firstly, what we know is that medical residents
who have performed a 30-hour shift
will make 460% more diagnostic errors
in the Intensive Care Unit.
Secondly, we know that,
if you're going to have elective surgery, let's say,
and your surgeon has slept less than six hours
in the previous 24,
they are 170% more likely to cause a major surgical error
such as rupturing a blood vessel or you know,
damaging or puncturing an organ.
Then the irony is that a medical resident
who's worked a 30-hour shift,
when they get back in their car to drive home
at the end of their shift,
they're 168% more likely to get into a car crash.
Now returning to the accident and emergency room
from which they probably came
but now as a patient, rather than a doctor.
And you know, I've tried with many other people
to lobby the medical institute and/or institution
and try to understand why is this the case.
And I think some of it has to do with the old boys network
that it's almost like a hazing that, you know,
we went through it, so you have to do it.
Man up, suit up, boot up, woman up,
you need to get through this, this is a rites of passage.
And again, it comes back to that idea
that thinking that you can fight mother nature and evolution
is just thick-headed and that's what--
I mean, I get the idea that you have to develop
a level of rigor and emotional resiliency
to handle that kind of job.
And there is something to be said for, you know,
putting people in challenging situations to see how they
function under high stress,
but the sleep deprivation aspect of it is just ridiculous.
You know, (mumbles) when you go through medical school,
you take an oath, which is to do no harm,
and then you're placed under conditions
of insufficient sleep that statistically
will guarantee that you will do more harm
than if you were sleeping or working at,
say just a 16-hour shift.
One of the push,
I think some of the pushback that you receive
or I've received is, look my mind's made up,
don't confuse me with the data.
And you think, okay, good--
You're the scientist--
What can I do?
You know, isn't this self-evident?
And one of the arguments though that I think
that has some legitimacy is that of continuity of care,
that if you are flip-flopping back and forth
between a resident, every six hours,
the continuity of the patient care can decrease.
But then I thought about that argument for a long time
and then I looked at a number of medical control, sorry,
the medical systems throughout the world.
And I asked, how long does it take to train their residents
and how good is their medical care?
And what I found is that there are places like New Zealand,
France, Switzerland,
they all have their residents working no more than 16 hours.
And their quality of healthcare
is actually ranked far better in the worldwide statistics
than the United States.
So, you can't tell me that you can't train an individual
within five years or less, at a reasonable amount of sleep
and not maintain high quality of medical practice.
Well, part of the problem tracks back to the fact
that there's no education on this in medical school, right?
So these doctors who then become hospital administrators,
don't have the proper background
to make a better decision about this.
That's exactly right.
So I also, you know, myself and some other researchers,
you look at the medical curriculum throughout many of these
first world nations.
And what you discover is that on average,
the average medical resident will receive somewhere between
an hour and a half to two hours of education on sleep.
Relative to the entire medical program.
Now that strikes me because,
that's one-third of their patients lives.
And that one-third of their life spent asleep
makes a profound difference about two-thirds
of waking health life.
Why aren't we investing more in the education of sleep
for our medical residents?
Well, why aren't we?
Have you seen since the book came out
and you've been speaking regularly on this,
have you seen changes, positive movement in this regard?
A little, but not, not too much.
Unfortunately.
I think there are some medical programs around this country
at least that are doing better than others.
There's, quite a variability.
So some are prioritizing it
and understanding its importance.
But overall no, I think that that same sort of
some of that hubris is still present.
What do we do to change that?
Well, you know, I tried early on speaking about this
from the statistics of the patients,
from a point of view of compassion and empathy
for our young residents.
And that sort of just falls on deaf ears.
What I realized is that you have to speak in a currency
with which, you know,
medical institutions and administrators will listen to,
which is dollars and cents.
And when you start to rack up the numbers
regarding malpractice suits caused by insufficient sleep--
Yeah, they tart paying attention.
They start paying attention.
So I was just stupid.
I thought about appealing in the wrong language.
You gotta follow the money.
Yeah, I know, yeah.
(both giggling)
But this, Halsted reminds me of,
that TV show, "The Knick".
Did you watch the show?
Steven Soderbergh did a limited series several years ago.
I think it was for Showtime, I can't remember.
But it's about this surgeon played by Clive Owen
at the turn of the century, it's literally 1900.
And he is,
he's like an opium addict and then he gets introduced
to cocaine and heroin, but he's,
he's this talented surgeon and he goes into the theater
and you see the crazy surgeries that they were doing
at the time.
It's quite an interesting document,
I think you would really like it, but I couldn't but think,
I wonder if this character is modeled after--
I suspect so.
I suspect if, you know, drug abuse, cocaine
and such was involved and he was this extraordinary power,
force that sort of birth into being, you know,
this new way of medical practice.
I, well, imagine it was based on--
Right, right, right.
Well, the relationship between substance and substance abuse
and addiction and sleep deprivation,
is another way in on this, you know, in this terrain.
I mean, when you're,
when you have all these doctors who are being compelled
to stay up so late,
they're gonna find exogenous ways of enhancing their ability
to do their jobs.
And the treatment center that I went to,
many years ago,
was known for having lots of doctors,
doctors and pilots, like the two people that you completely,
sort of divest yourself of any, of all control over to.
And I just remember being struck at how many surgeons
and pilots were in this treatment center, right?
Like there was a brain surgeon who was a morphine addict
and there was all kinds of pilots
that were addicted to Vicodin.
There were anesthesiologists that were fentanyl addicts,
they would steal it when they would not use the entire vial.
And they were using them,
primarily so that they could function in their job capacity.
That's right, yeah.
That's how it starts.
To sort of try to come, you know,
back from the disruption.
But what we know is that the,
the risk or the probability
of someone abusing drugs of abuse
in the medical profession is significantly higher
than the general population.
To me, a more striking and, well,
an equally striking and equally worrisome statistic recently
is that the rates of suicide,
are far higher in young residents.
And what we've discovered over the past,
maybe 10 years, and we've been doing a lot of this work too,
is the intimate relationship between sleep
and your mental health.
And, what we know is that when you are not getting
sufficient sleep,
your suicidal thoughts increase,
suicidal planning increases, suicide attempts increase,
and tragically suicide completion also increases as well.
And more generally what we've discovered,
and I've been doing this for about 20 years now,
we have not been able to discover
a single psychiatric condition in which sleep is normal.
And so I think sleep has a profound story to tell,
and our understanding, our treatment,
maybe even our prevention of grave mental illness.
Well, certainly in saying that
it should be the first stop
on the kind of treatment protocol, right?
Like how is your sleep?
Let's deal with that first,
before we look at pharmaceutical interventions.
Yeah, it's a stabilizing force
and we know it's a stabilizing force,
both in terms of your psychology
as we mentioned impulsivity,
but also just from a basic reward brain sensitivity
that your addiction potential
from a brain perspective is higher with insufficient sleep.
Same individual, two different sleep conditions,
two different addictive profiles.
Wow. I have to reassess my whole life now.
Oh, I'm so sorry-
No, it's fine.
No, it's good.
I wanna talk about sleep in adolescents and teens,
'cause I think the work that you're doing here
and the issues that you're trying to, you know,
raise awareness around are super important.
The implications of chronic sleep deprivation
in young people, the relationship to, you know,
early school hours and how this plays out
in terms of academic potential
and the mental health implications that you just mentioned.
Yeah, so there's been a remarkable amount of work,
looking at this issue of early school start times,
this incessant model of marching back the school clock hours
and the summary of the evidence, really
I think it goes the following.
Firstly, we see that academic,
when you shift schools to a later school start time.
So when you do a causal intervention, what happens?
Firstly the academic grades increase,
the truancy rates decrease,
psychological and psychiatric referrals also decrease.
But what we also discovered is that the life expectancy
of those students increased.
And you may think, well, hang on a second,
how does that work?
Well, the leading cause of death
in late stage adolescent teens is actually not suicide,
it's road traffic accidents,
and here sleep matters enormously.
And there was one good example,
I think it came from Teton County in Wyoming.
They shifted their school start times
from around 07:30 in the morning
to just before nine o'clock in the morning.
The only thing more remarkable than the extra hour of sleep
that those kids reported getting,
was the drop in road traffic accidents.
That following year after the time switch,
there was a 70%, seven zero reduction
in car crashes in students, 16 to 18.
Statistically unbelievable.
It blows my mind.
Now, you know, statistically,
you can give a relevance to that.
Think of the advent of ABS systems in cars,
anti-lock brake systems
that stop your wheels from locking up into heartbreaking.
That dropped accident rates by around 20 to 25%
and it was deemed a revolution.
Yet here is a simple biological factor,
giving our kids the sleep that they need
that will drop accident rates by up to 70%.
So if our goal as educators truly is to educate
and not risk lives in the process,
then we are failing our children
in the most spectacular manner
with this incessant model of early school start times.
When sleep is abundant, minds flourish,
when it's not, they don't.
There's so much education
I think that that needs to be done in this area.
As a parent of two teens, I've got four kids, two are boys.
Any parent knows how difficult it is to wake up
a young adolescent in the morning
and the frustration that comes with that.
But what I've come to better understand
by dent of your work,
is how crucial sleep is for that developing brain.
And during COVID we have one child,
our younger child who's being homeschooled right now.
We've let her sleep in as long as she wants
and we don't start her first class until noon.
And so she's getting a ton of sleep,
but if you even tried to wake her up at nine o'clock,
I mean, forget it,
you're gonna spend the next hour and a half
trying to get this kid up.
So clearly there's a reason why that state of sleep
is so deep, right?
Like that, it is crucial in this developing, you know,
in this developing mind.
Yeah, and you know, we often have that classic idea of,
you know, a parent at the weekend, pulling the sheets off,
you know, the teenagers ripping open the curtains--
The trauma of wasting the--
And saying, you know,
you're wasting the day.
But firstly, what we know is that it's not their fault,
because during that adolescent transition,
there is a biological shift in their 24-hour rhythm
that they now want to go to bed later and wake up later.
So asking a teenager to wake up at seven o'clock
in the morning and operate and conduct themselves
with good grace and be able to learn effectively
is like (indistinct) an adults to, you know,
to wake up at 03:30 or 04:00 in the morning
and be the best version of yourself.
If I was to wake up at three o'clock in the morning
and come through to the kitchen and oh, we both wake,
I'd have to say to my partner, you know,
I would say, "Look darling."
And she would say like,
"Why are you so a moody?"
I'm just not the best version of myself
'cause I've woken up too early
and she will definitely tell you that.
But I think it's, it's the same, you know,
misgiving because we don't understand how sleep works
with our teenagers.
And so putting them in the school at that time
seven or eight in the morning essentially is, you know,
educating them amnesic.
at that stage they are leaky sieves and what will go in,
will just come out the other side.
So that's the first thing that's happening.
It's not their fault, it's just their biology.
And then second at the weekend,
they're trying to sleep off a debt that we've lumbered them
with during the week
because of these early school start times.
And if you ask parents,
if you sort of question parents of teenagers,
what proportion of parents think that their teen
is getting sufficient sleep and more than 70% of them say,
I think my teen is doing fine.
I think they're getting the sleep of need.
When in reality, less than 15% of those teens
are actually getting the sleep that they need.
So there is a parent to child mismatch
in sleep understanding.
And as a consequence, there is a parent to child
transmission of sleep neglect.
Parents don't see it. They don't understand it.
And so, you know, in 15 or you know, 10 or 20 years time
that teenager lo and behold seems to have amnesia
and they, with their own kids will do the same thing.
They'll pull the sheets off and say,
you're wasting the day because it was taught to them
by their parents that sleep and getting the right timing
of sleep and the right amount of sleep
is something shameful.
So for that young person, do they need more hours?
They do, so--
The eight hour rule doesn't really apply.
No that's for adults.
And in fact, the brain doesn't stop developing
until it's about 25 years old
and sleep plays a critical role
in what we call brain plasticity,
which is modeling the brain.
It plays a role early in life in the first couple of years,
sleep seems to actually help wire up the brain.
So it's almost like sleep at that time of life comes in
to a new neighborhood and like an internet service provider,
it wires all of those homes
with high-speed fiber optic cables.
But then later in life, that's when during the teenage years
we've actually realized
which homes are using the high bandwidth
and which homes aren't really sort of drawing
on that sort of, you know, that broad band speed.
And so then the role of the brain, it goes from expanding,
creating lots of connections, which is called neurogenesis
to then actually synaptic pruning,
which is where we now have to make the brain efficient
for adulthood.
We sculpt away the unnecessary and we keep the necessary
and sleep performs that role too in later teenage years.
And as a consequence,
if you are chronically under sleeping a teenager,
you're effectively stunting brain development,
and no one would wish that for that child.
Right, so you impede neurogenesis.
So there's fewer pathways to choose from.
And then as you age, then you're selecting,
you're basically, you have less to choose from, right?
So you're just limiting the CA the brain's capacity
to do its job well.
So early in life in the first five or so years,
you want to sort of, you know,
it's almost spray and pray attitude
a little bit like in investing,
you just, you know, gift all regions of the brain
lots of connections.
And then you let experience and time teach the brain
which highways and sort of trippy trees and avenues
and lanes would you like to keep
and which should be removed.
So now, as you shift later in life,
it's all about efficiency. Let's get this brain efficient.
'Cause right now,
when you've got this too much connectivity,
it's good to sort of as a general blueprint to lay down,
but then let life tell you which of those sort of networks
you should enhance and which you should actually remove.
And if later in life that we're removing those.
And as I said, it's not until we're about 25,
that the brain has finished all of that maturation.
And that's why the recommendation
is seven to nine hours in adults.
And I would argue in adults once they're past 25 years old,
before that you'd need much more sleep.
So what would be the ideal amount of sleep
for the adolescent or young teen?
Yeah, it's usually somewhere between eight to 10 hours
and going up to maybe 11 hours depending on the teen.
And if people wanna find out,
there's a great informational sheet,
they can just go to the national sleep foundation.
It's the nationalsleepfoundation.org.
And you can look at the current guidelines
that we and other scientists have sort of tried to
gather all of the information say, look,
where should we position these windows of sleep duration
based on different age ranges.
So it's a great resource if people are thinking about that
for their kids and for themselves as well.
If you could bend the ear of the secretary of education,
I mean, what would be your recommendation
in terms of school start time, like 09:00 a.m.?
I think for teenagers, I would say 10:00 a.m.
10:00.
10:00 the minimum.
And what's interesting is that the younger kids,
they can actually wake up earlier
'cause they haven't gone through that adolescent transition.
So, they probably could be going to school
and learning effectively at let's say 09:00 a.m.
or even 08:30 a.m.
But in those studies, they carefully asked the question.
We can't set different times for different age brackets.
You know, that's just not practical.
And I understand
why there is resistance in the school system.
You can say, why aren't we starting that early?
Some of it has to do a little bit with the bus unions,
the bus networks that tried to get kids to school.
And I get that.
I get, you know, it's not an easy problem to solve,
but I also realized that we've put people on the moon
and I think we can solve--
Even tougher problems to solve.
And so I'm not trivializing it.
It's a big problem and I don't have all of the answers.
I'm just the scientist.
Well, there's the kind of mechanistic logistical aspect
of solving that problem.
But there's also the mental hurdle
which comes with education, right?
Like getting somebody's head wrapped around the idea
of why a 10:00 a.m. school start
is in the best interest of the child is a hurdle.
And you know, for most parents, that's the genetic legacy.
That's what you--
They're like,
I gotta get to work too.
Like, what am I supposed to, you know, so.
And, and that's the hard part.
So what they did is they looked at say,
okay, let's say that we started school at 10 o'clock,
that's only gonna help the teenagers,
but would it hurt the kids who are younger
because that would then say, well,
we can't do this one time fits all phenomenon.
And what they found is that it didn't hurt the younger kids.
They were learning just as effectively,
but in the teenagers,
they were learning far more effectively.
In fact, if you look across the day and you ask,
where are those school start times
really hurting the teenagers,
it's in the first half of the day,
because they're mostly asleep
and you ask any high school teacher,
what does my class look like first thing in the morning
versus in the afternoon?
They are usually very different as an audience.
What about,
dealing with things like SSRIs and,
and treating ADHD with Adderall and Ritalin
and, you know, the overmedication of our young people
and the implication on sleep and brain development.
Yeah, I wrote a little bit about this in the book.
It is unfortunate that if you look at ADHD,
the current recommended treatment are things like Adderall
and Ritalin.
And they are some versions of something
that looks very much like amphetamine.
And I'm not dismissing the idea that ADHD exists.
I'm not one of those people, it clearly does.
I also am not anti-medication by any means.
But what I would say is that,
unfortunately, those medications
are very strong, wake promoting medications.
I mean, if you ask an amphetamine addict, you know,
if they need sleep, when they using amphetamines,
they will laugh at you, right?
They'll say, are you kidding me?
I can go straight without sleep.
And so maybe we need to think differently
about at least the timing of that medication.
Do we wanna be medicating kids in the morning
or in the evening?
Because if those things are wake promoting,
we know that kids with ADHD have non-normal sleep,
they actually have disrupted sleep.
And we're also starting to find that those medications
themselves are sleep disruptors.
And so one wonders what would be the efficacy,
the benefit of those medications, which there are,
but just timed correctly.
And you are at least able to try and protect sleep.
Or what if we could just come up with better medications
that aren't so destructive to sleep?
I think that to me would be a better approach.
Is there research on antidepressant medication
like the SSRIs and the implications for sleep?
There are, yeah.
So sleep is usually not normative
when you're taking antidepressants.
Now that's a general statement and it's too general in fact.
It really depends on which type of antidepressant,
because different antidepressants
will shift different neurochemical systems in the brain.
So SSRIs stands for Selective Serotonin Reuptake Inhibitor.
And serotonin is a key neurochemical
in the regulation of sleep.
We have found historically
that people taking antidepressants
will typically have a reduction in REM sleep.
It really seems to hit hard on REM sleep.
And as we may come on to discuss sleep
and particularly REM sleep
provides a form of emotional first aid.
REM sleep is what I've described as overnight therapy.
And there's nothing that I've seen that, you know,
sort of is that much further from its effect size
based on the evidence.
And so one wonders whether or not
we can look to alternative medications
that again, have at least some conceptual sensitivity
to the things that regulate sleep
and try to stay away from disrupting sleep.
If sleep offers some form of assistance to depression,
and we know that insufficient sleep predicts depression,
we know that people who are depressed don't sleep very well,
they have abnormal sleep patterns.
So if sleep is a part of that disorder
and disordered sleep as a part of depression,
then shouldn't we think about the medications that they take
that are also sleep disruptive.
And maybe think about finding ways where we time again,
the onset of the medication.
I don't know how many doctors described to their patients,
not just take two of these, but when you know,
seven o'clock in the morning could be very different
than seven o'clock in the evening.
In fact, that's true of many medications
in terms of their sleep disruptive capacity.
For somebody who, for whatever reason schedule-wise,
or whatnot, can't seem to carve out
the eight hours of sleep a night,
can this be made up for through napping
or by phasic or polyphasic sleep
like there always seems to be people
who are doing all kinds of experiments
with polyphasic sleep.
But to my mind, I mean,
you know, obviously more way more than I do,
but it seems like those experiments always
like somebody who's like,
I'm just gonna sleep every two hours, every four hours,
but that never lasts very long.
They always end up going back.
No. It doesn't serve.
That sort of idea of what's called highly polyphasic sleep.
As some people describe it as the Uber man sort of schedule,
some people have said DaVinci once described it--
It's part of this like self optimization--
Biohacking.
Kind of thing
but it doesn't work.
Not good a idea.
No, it really doesn't.
And you know, there is nothing in our biology
that would suggest that's how we should be sleeping.
And in fact, it's quite the opposite.
In fact, there's a lot in our biology screaming,
you should not be sleeping like that.
You're not designed to be highly polyphasic in your sleep,
meaning multiple bouts of sleep.
The only time that we do that is when we're infants,
you know, and it's sort of,
I think Billy Crystal is a long time insomniac.
He's got this joke and he says, "You know,
I sleep like a baby.
I'm awake every two hours."
and that seems to be this highly polyphasic mentality too.
So that doesn't seem to be the case.
That doesn't seem to be how we should sleep.
And I would strongly advise people not to do that.
Should we be sleeping though differently
than the way that we are in modernity?
And I actually think there is an argument for this,
because if you look at hunter, gatherer tribes,
whose way of life hasn't changed for thousands of years,
they don't sleep the way that we do.
They don't sleep in what we call the monophasic pattern,
which is trying to get one long single bout at night
and then we're awake for 16 hours.
They sleep biphasically.
So typically depending on what season,
be it Winter versus Summer,
they will sleep for anywhere between sort of six
to seven hours at night,
and then they will have the siesta like behavior
in the afternoon where they have a nap,
getting this sort of fuller opportunity.
So I think modernity, you could argue
has actually dislocated us from how our natural edict
of sleep schedule.
Is there any other evidence to support that?
There actually is.
Most people will know this somewhere between about
02:00 to 04:00 p.m every day,
you will have a drop of pre-programmed
and it's genetically hardwired drop in your alertness.
It's sort of, you know,
that you're around the boardroom table after lunch
and all of a sudden you start
to see these head bobs going on,
that's not people listening to good music
there that just giving way to what we call
the postprandial dip in alertness.
And it is decoupled on some level from the food comma.
Like part of it is, "Oh, I ate a big lunch."
But this is independent of that.
You can prevent people from having lunch
and they still have, you know,
put electrodes on their head,
we can still measure this alertness drop.
So it is independent of food.
Right, so siesta.
So siesta, you know, and you can ask, well,
if that is how we were designed to sleep,
is there any evidence that something goes wrong
when you change that natural behavior?
And that actually happened as a natural,
well, an unfortunate natural experiment in Greece,
a couple of decades ago.
They decided that they were going to do away
with the siesta policy.
So if you went to Greece, you know, in the 1980s
and you walked around the towns,
you would see on the shop windows,
it would say open from 10:00 to 02:00 p.m.,
close from 02:00 to 05:00 p.m.
and then open from 05:00 to 10:00 p.m.
because there was a standardized siesta practice.
They decided to do away with that.
And so Harvard researchers said, okay,
we're going to see what happens, what are the consequences?
And they focused on cardiovascular disease.
So they tracked the sleep
and the health cardiovascular health
of well over 23,000 Greeks.
And what they found is that across that five-year period,
there was a 70, sorry, there was a 37% increased likelihood
of having a heart attack.
In fact, it was worse in males.
In males, there was a 60% increase
in likelihood of having a heart attack.
And what was happening, it seemed if you looked at the data,
is that they were still sleeping the same,
maybe just six hours a night.
And they were doing away with a nap during the day.
And they weren't replacing that sleep time
back into their night phase.
They were staying true to what they'd been doing before
at night, and they'd just been short-changed of their sleep
during the day and that led
to cardiovascular health consequences.
So if no siesta, you gotta make you get the eight hours.
But if you're doing,
if you're engaging in that hunter-gatherer practice,
you can go six and two or whatever.
And that seems to be fine.
I would say that there's probably a couple of caveats
with naps though.
Naps are a double-edged sword.
If you are struggling with sleep at night,
the recommendation is, do not nap during the day,
because what you want to do
is build up all of that healthy sleepiness.
And it's a chemical called adenosine.
It's sleep pressure essentially.
And the longer that you've been awake,
the more of that adenosine,
the more of that sleep pressure builds up.
And it's not a mechanical pressure in your brain.
Don't worry ,it's a chemical pressure to sleep.
And then after about 16 hours of being awake,
there seems to be enough adenosine,
enough sort of sleepiness to be weighing down
on your shoulders, that now you can fall asleep
and then stay asleep.
So if you're someone who has fragile sleep or insomnia,
you shouldn't nap during the day
because taking a nap during the day
will actually just, it's almost like,
like a pressure valve on a steam cooker.
You just release some of that healthy sleep pressure
that's been building up.
And now when it comes time to fall asleep
or stay asleep at night, it's that much harder.
So the advice would be, if you can,
if you don't have sleep problems and you can nap regularly,
then I would say, naps are just fine.
But if you can't do it regularly,
and especially if you suffer from sleep problems,
try to stay away from naps.
If you are going to nap,
nap before 02:00 p.m. in the afternoon,
going later than that can be problematic for your sleep.
It's a little bit like snacking before your main meal.
It just takes the edge off your appetite.
It's the same way with naps.
I'm sure, you or somebody has studied
what happens if you take exogenous adenosine, right?
Like wouldn't that seem to be the way in
to resolving this problem for people that have insomnia.
How to get it across the blood-brain barrier
which is a protective layer on the brain.
And there's some issues around toxicity as well.
So yeah, that certainly would have been the idea,
but what's lovely is that, you know,
you can increase sort of sleep pressure
in a number of non-pharmacological ways.
And exercise is a great demonstration of that.
And I think, we can speak about all of these different
over the counter medications
that people try to invest in,
think that that's going to give them
a good night of sleep,
but there are probably two really simple things
that you can do non-medication that are,
if you look at the data are almost guaranteed to improve
your sleep, which is some form of physical activity
most days, or at least several days a week.
And the second is deal with your anxiety.
Anxiety is the principle cause of insomnia.
It's not the only cause, but it's the,
our current working model of insomnia
that people who have high fight or flight activation
of the nervous system, branch of the nervous system,
they also have high levels of stress chemicals
such as cortisol.
And that seems to be very predictive of their insomnia.
And if you can start to manage your anxiety, for example,
meditation is a fantastic practice.
And, before I was writing the book
and I was sort of starting to research,
I was a bit of a stupid hard-nosed scientist.
I just thought this meditation stuff was maybe
a little bit woo-woo, and sort of kumbaya
and we all hold hands.
And I started to look at the data.
The data was immensely powerful and very robust
that people, when they are suffering from insomnia,
if you put them into a meditation and mindful practice,
you can actually drop the severity of the insomnia
in a way that medications such,
even prescription medications can't come close to.
Yeah, I mean, I just know, well, first of all,
if I don't exercise forget about it,
I know I'm gonna struggle with sleep--
Yeah, me too.
At night.
And. if and when I have difficulty falling asleep
or I wake up in the middle of the night,
I've become very attuned to what my mind is doing.
And it will generally default to some problem
that I'm having or conflict that I'm trying to resolve.
And I'll just loop some narrative.
And that produces a tremendous amount of anxiety,
which obviously prevents me from falling asleep.
So I noticed that, and then I course correct
through either some kind of mindfulness practice
to kind of create space and push that narrative aside
or overcome it with a different narrative.
And sometimes I'll just think about a book that I'm reading
or a movie that I saw,
and I'll just immerse myself in that narrative.
And that, that's like a distraction.
Exactly.
Literally,
short circuits that other anxiety producing narrative
and I fall asleep.
You're so right.
So I think, you know, in this modern day and age,
sort of, you know, that empty fee,
fast food, 24/7 society,
we're constantly on sort of reception,
particularly with now all of this digital technology
and rarely do we do reflection.
Unfortunately the one time when we do reflection
is when a head hits the pillow.
And that's the last time
that you want to go into rumination.
You don't want the Rolodex of anxiety spinning up,
which is what you were sort of describing
because that leads to something
that we call catastrophization
that you start thinking, oh, what didn't I do today?
And what do I need to do more of tomorrow?
And then I forgot this.
And at that point,
good sleep is not going to be invited into the brain.
By the way, counting sheep does not work.
There was a scientific study done by a colleague of mine
at UC Berkeley.
That demonstrated in fact, if anything, it hurts your sleep.
And what-
If your catastrophizing,
it would probably be better to start counting sheep.
It could be, but what you described
was actually what she found.
Far better was to engage in some kind of a mental aspect
and what they found was take yourself on a walk,
think about a walk that, you know,
in the forest or in nature or down on the beach,
and just start to try to walk yourself through that
or think about a book that you're reading
or think about sort of a podcast
and anything to get the mind off itself.
So for example, I'm, I feel embarrassed to say this,
but I love racing cars.
And so if I'm struggling with sleep, which I have, I do too,
I am not immune to bad nights of sleep.
And I have had bouts of insomnia.
So comforting to hear that.
I'm just as fragile.
And so what I'll do is I'll put myself
and I'll think about the track
and I'll drive myself around the track.
I know when I need to, which gear I need to be
and where my broken breaking zones are.
And then the next thing I know
is I'm waking up in the morning
and, I just drifted off--
And that's great, it's sort of a different version
of what I do.
What kind of cars do you race?
Oh, gosh, I've raced all sorts.
BMW's, Porsche's, but my real love and the car that I own
is a little (indistinct).
When you're a professor you can't really go racing
in half million dollar cars.
And I love it to pieces.
It is a car unlike, Ferrari or Porsche,
when you're going 40 miles an hour,
it feels like you're doing a 100.
Whereas in a Porsche, when you're doing a 100,
it feels like 40 miles an hour.
So I'm usually the slowest guy on track,
but it brings me a lot of joy and satisfaction.
That's cool.
Well, let's talk a little bit about best practices then,
I feel like we're at that, at that juncture.
And I wanna do this by walking you through
the extreme lengths that (giggles).
I knew a little bit (indistinct)
tend to include it.
I sleep in a tent,
it causes a lot of consternation and confusion from people
that, that listened to this show,
but I'll just provide a little background to that.
Like historically have had issues falling asleep,
part of it and I'm interested in your take on this
is I think my sense is that
it germinates somewhat from being
like an extreme ultra endurance athlete.
I've gone through periods of my life,
where I've put my body through just unbelievable rigor,
like 25 hour training weeks where you're just so exhausted.
Sleep is a non-issue I sleep is not a problem
when you're pushing yourself that hard,
but it's been many years
since I've been kind of habiting that space
and now, but I've, but I've acclimated my physical body
has acclimated to doing that.
So now if I go out for a one-hour run
or I go on a casual bike ride, it's not enough.
Like I'm not getting enough of the fatigue
to create the restful state that I aspire to be in.
Like, I really, I have to exercise
more than the average person,
which is challenging when you're a busy person.
So there's that.
On top of that, my body's like a furnace
like I literally burn hot and my wife likes the bedroom
a lot warmer than, than I do.
And we would have this back and forth over many years
where it's too cold for her,
I'm on top of all the covers
she's underneath them, shivering it, wasn't working.
And as kind of a joke,
I went and we have a flat roof off of our bedroom.
And I went and I just, you know,
pulled a twin mattress up there and slept there one night
and had an unbelievable night of sleep.
I thought this is fantastic.
It's nice and cold out that desert air, even in the summer.
And that I graduated from that into getting a tent
and I've been sleeping in a tent ever since.
I absolutely love it.
The cold air being under the stars
and being under a bunch of blankets,
including a gravity blanket,
which I'd love your thoughts on,
which I found to be really helpful,
speaking about the sympathetic nervous system
and trying to calm myself down.
And eye mask and nature sounds and, you know, magnesium,
like all kinds of stuff.
And the idea being of course,
to create the optimal situation for the best opportunity
for eight hours of sleep every night.
And like yourself, I don't always,
despite all of that,
sleep still alludes me any nights,
but more often than not,
I'm getting more high-quality sleep than I used to.
But I'm interested in how this kind of measures up
with what you found through your studies
about best practices, specifically temperature, air quality,
all these kinds of things. So.
Yeah. And so I think there are probably maybe five tips
for better sleep tonight if you sort of can suggest that
or start trying to optimize your sleep.
And temperature, regularity, darkness,
walk it out and then alcohol and caffeine.
And I'll save it for the last one,
'cause usually if you don't find me deeply
unappealing right now, you will, after that fifth one,
temperature is a fascinating one.
We know that your brain and your body needs
to drop their core temperature
by about one degree Celsius
or about two to three degrees Fahrenheit
for you to fall asleep
and then stay asleep across the night.
And that's the reason that you'll always find it easier
to fall asleep in a room that's too cold than too hot.
Because too cold is taking you
in the right thermal direction for good sleep.
And that's why sleeping in a tent.
Now we understand we're in Southern California,
but nevertheless, you know, it can get,
it gets cooler at night than it is during the day.
I wouldn't be doing this in Boston, right?
It's still, I mean, typically it's low 40s
and it goes down into the high 30s
and I've never not slept in the tent
because it was too cold.
I know that in your research,
you've found, there is an inflection point
at which point, perhaps, you know, too cold is not so good?
Yeah, once you get into an extreme.
But I have to tell you, like, you know,
when it's 38 degrees, I'm happy.
Like when I sleep pretty dang well.
I mean, I got a lot of blankets on.
Yeah. And so it's sort of, you know,
the local temperature may not quite be there-
It might. And here's the other thing,
I always have my feet sticking out.
I cannot have my feet under the covers.
And do you know why?
Yeah, I think I know, but go ahead.
Because it's your hands and your feet
that are these incredible radiators of heat,
your hands and your feet are highly vascular.
In other words, there is this crisscross of vessels,
very close to the surface.
And it's very rich in its vascular nature,
both your hands and your feet.
And so at night,
what the body wants to do is almost like a snake charmer,
draw the heat out of the core of the body
and evacuate it through the extremities
and the extremities in this case for us human beings,
are hands and feet, as well as head.
And that's why you will sometimes see rebellious.
When you see kids and you kind of took them in all nicely,
and you know, you look at your wife and you smile,
it is all beautiful,
and then you go back in two hours later
just before you go to bed
and these rebellious legs dangling out, sticking out,
it's because you're trying to evacuate the heat.
So you're wise in doing that
because they are wonderful thermal discharges.
So that's temperature.
And we do need to drop that temperature.
It's different for different people
but I think the recommendation would probably be about,
you know, 65 degrees or so for most people.
Now that's obviously averaging across men and women.
And it's different there too, as you mentioned,
which is around about, if I do my math correctly,
it's probably around about 18, 18.3 degrees Celsius.
So that's temperature
and that's why I think you definitely will start to sleep
better than you at least would do otherwise
on a constant temperature.
Because there's another way that modernity has dislocated us
from our natural edict of sleep,
which is we set a thermostat of maybe 70 or 72 degrees
throughout the day in the night.
And that's not how we were, we're sleeping.
Now, if you go back to those Hunter gatherers, by the way,
for whom you are,
in some ways mimicking their sleeping existence,
they don't go to bed really on the basis of light,
which is what we thought.
They usually will go to bed about an hour and a half
to two hours after sundown.
And then when they wake up and they don't have alarms,
if you ask them about this idea of, you know,
artificially terminating sleep with an alarm,
they're perplexed
also, you know, rates of insomnia
in the general first world population
is somewhere between 10 to 15%.
In those hunter-gatherer tribes, it's less than 5%.
So some things-
They're also moving
all day long.
They're moving all day long.
And you know, we can look at diet as well,
but so what is determining their sleep onset
and their sleep offset, it's not light it's temperature.
So when the, and if you ask people,
if you just bring them into the laboratory and you say,
you know, what point do you feel sleepy at night?
It's at the point where their core body temperature
is on the steepest decline.
Now they don't know that even though,
unfortunately we've placed a rectal probe inside of them,
which is no fun for either of the experiment
to insert or for the participant to receive,
but they are on the awesome down slope
of that thermal evacuation and that's when they feel sleepy.
And when there was hunter-gatherer tribes wished to wake up
is before dawn, just before dawn,
but it's as the temperature starts to rise back up.
So it turns out that we actually need
to warm up a little bit to get cold.
We need to bring the blood to the surface of the skin.
That's why cold, it must be in the bedroom,
but you can wear socks if you want,
or you can have a hot water bottle,
but keep it cold because warming the feet
or sticking them out of the mattress
will help your body evacuate the heat
and plummet your core body temperature.
And it's the reason by the way that hot baths and showers
work for good sleep as well.
You know , you think--
In a kind of intuitive way, right?
'Cause you think you're warming up-
And you're nice and toasty.
You're valves are dilating.
When you get out of the bath, you got rosy cheeks.
All of the blood comes to the surface.
And when you get out of the bath,
your core body temperature is dropping precipitously.
That's why you fall asleep.
It's called the warm bath effect in sleep science.
It's so reliable.
And then when they're starting to wake up
is when they're starting to warm up.
So we need to sort of warm up to get cold, to get to sleep.
Then we need to stay cold to stay asleep.
And then we need to warm up to wake up.
If that's the sort of temperature transition.
So that's temperature.
The next is regularity.
Go to bed at the same time and wake up at the same time,
no matter whether it's the weekday or the weekend,
or even if you've had a bad night of sleep,
don't change it, resist the urge.
My recommendation to people
who've had a bad night of insomnia.
They'll say, should I get to bed earlier?
Should I wake up later?
Do nothing.
Don't go to bed any earlier, don't try to wake up any later.
Keep to your schedule and by the way,
I'm giving these sort of, these tips or these rules,
people don't respond to rules.
People respond to reasons, not rules
and that's why I am,
if you don't mind.
(indistinct) diplomat.
Trying to give some explanation (indistinct).
so underlying it.
But the reason that regularity is king
is because it will anchor your sleep
and it will improve the quantity
and the quality of that sleep
because deep within your brain,
there is a master 24 hour clock and it expects regularity
and thrives best under conditions of regularity,
including the regulation of your sleep wake schedule.
Sorry, I just wanna interrupt with one thing,
which is on that subject of the internal clock,
does it matter in the context of getting eight hours?
If you choose to go to bed at nine o'clock or you go to bed
at 11 o'clock, if you're getting eight hours,
is that going to impact the quality of your sleep?
Like I know personally, like I need to go to bed early.
If I still get eight hours, but I go to bed late.
It's not the same thing.
Yeah. And so we mentioned that overall
for the average adult, you get most of your deep sleep
in the first half of the night.
Most of your REM sleep in the second half of the night,
but it's not quite that simple.
And by the way, some people will say to me,
isn't the sleep that you get before midnight
twice as valuable as that, that you get after midnight,
and there's nothing, you know,
the stroke of midnight there's nothing about the sleep
that you were getting at 11:59 p.m.
and the sleep that you're getting at 12:01 a.m.,
and that's a fallacy.
But what you described is important and it's a nuance
and it comes back to what we call chronotype.
Are you a morning type evening type or somewhere in between.
And it's about a third split across the population.
You don't get to decide.
It's not, if you're a night owl, it's not your fault.
It's gifted by way, largely of your genetics.
It was gifted to you at birth and it is hardwired.
And we now know the genes,
at least six different genes determine
whether you're a morning lark or an evening owl
or sitting somewhere in between.
But it's interesting to know
that that's a genetic disposition.
You can't compel a night owl to be a morning person.
No people have done all sorts of incredible things.
And there is some degree of wiggle room you can do.
I think there's five or six different things
that they tried,
but all you can really do is drag a night owl back by,
maybe 30 minutes and that's really it.
So what you're describing there,
in terms of the quality of your sleep is important
because it's less about where any adult places
that eight hours on the 24 hour clock face,
it's more about where that individual adult
is trying to sleep in harmony with their chronotype
rather than against their chronotype.
Now, unfortunately, modernity is predisposed
to a heavy bias and a discrimination towards morning types.
It's this type A culture that rise and grind,
you get up in the morning
and it's all about the early bird catches the worm.
Well, I can also tell you that, the second mouse the cheese.
so you need to be really mindful of your chronotype.
Now you can figure out your chronotype, if you want,
you can just go online and you can,
what's the best probably search something called
morningness-eveningness questionnaire.
And I can send you a link that we can even put
in the show notes, the MEQ, and it's a series of questions.
And you will determine what type you are,
trying to then sleep at the right timing
in accordance in harmony
rather than in D synchrony with your chronotype
is when you will get the best quality of sleep.
That's why you say, if I go to bed at midnight
and I sleep in it until eight,
sometimes I kind of have a sleep hangover.
I just feel miserable.
But if I get to bed at whatever time you normally do
earlier in the evening and wake up earlier,
that's my sweet spot.
Most people probably know what their type is?
They do.
Well, I think yes and no, because you know,
in some ways, even the middle ground folks
will think that they are,
perhaps more evening type than they actually are
because of technology.
Now, we've done a lot of work in the sleep field.
We, the Royal we, by the way, in this podcast,
when I've said we did something, I mean, that sort of,
or when I say I did something-
The sleep science community.
I mean, we did something,
and when I say we did something, I mean they did something.
But so we've done a lot of work looking at technology
and the invasion of technology into our lives
and into our evenings and into the bedroom.
And certainly those blue light devices
are damaging to the release of melatonin,
which we'll come on to when we speak about darkness,
but it's not really that which now seems to be carrying
the vote of technology based sleep disruption,
it's that these things are activating.
They are designed to capture your attention
and make you more alert.
And in fact, it's what ends up happening
is that you have sleep procrastination
where you're using these devices,
you're working on your laptop
and you think, ah, I'm not sleepy, I don't feel tired.
But if there were to be some electromagnetic pulse
that wiped out all of technology,
what you would realize is that at 10:30,
all the lights went out you couldn't do anything.
Within five or 10 minutes, you think,
wow, gosh, actually, you know what?
I really am sleepy.
And technology will mask your sleepiness.
That activating nature of technology hits the mute button
on your sleepiness.
So you don't perceive it.
In a multi-faceted way.
There's the dopamine induction of social media scrolling,
but there's also the light spectrum and all of that.
That's impacting your body's ability
to properly self-regulate.
Yep. Yeah.
And so, you know, I often,
if you really have to take your phone into your bedroom,
I don't personally, but again, you know, that's just me,
I would say the one rule I would offer to you
is that if you're gonna be using your phone in the bedroom,
you have to be standing up.
And at that point, after about five or six minutes,
We're not doing this anymore.
You're like, do you know what?
I just wanna, if you sit down on the bed,
I'm sorry, phone goes away.
Here's what's depressing though,
and you talk about this,
like how long before you need to go to bed,
should you shut the screen off?
And it was like a number of hours, right?
Like if you watch a movie and then go to bed,
that movie should be concluded
like, I don't know, what did you say?
Like two hours or something like that?
Well, it depends on sort of
watching television or a movie,
as long as it's not inside of the bedroom.
We really shouldn't be watching television
inside of the bedroom 'cause you wanna associate your bed
with simply the place of being asleep or for intimacy,
that's really what we recommend the bed for.
Don't be working on there, don't be eating on your bed.
Don't be watching television on your bed, consuming Netflix.
And I think it's really about computers
and, iPads and cell phones or laptops, sorry, tablets.
I think watching television outside of the bedroom is okay.
One of the dangers, however, when I ask people, you know,
if they say I'm having sleep problems,
I'll say, do you nap during the day?
And they'll say, "No, I know I never nap."
Then I'll say well, but when you watching television
on the couch in the evening,
do you sometimes fall asleep watching television?
They say, "Yeah, I do that all the time."
That's an accidental nap.
And it's the worst time to nap too,
because again, it's right before your main meal of sleep.
So I would say that if you're doing something
that helps you wind down and just disengage from the day,
disengage from those stresses, that's fine.
Be it reading a book, watching a mindless movie,
but in the last hour before bed stay away from anything
that you know is cognitively and especially emotionally
activating, don't be checking emails,
don't be sending texts,
don't be engaging in movies that are, you know,
action, horror movies that have you wired.
Try to stay away from those things.
So let's talk about caffeine and alcohol.
So disappointingly caffeine
has like an eight hour half-life.
So if you have a cup of coffee in the morning,
you're still contending with it when you go to bed.
It's tough, yeah.
So alcohol and caffeine.
So everyone knows that caffeine is an alerting substance.
It's in a class of drugs
that we call the psychoactive stimulants.
Interesting, it's one of the only psychoactive stimulants
that we readily give to children without too much concern.
So, many people know that that's how caffeine works,
but people may not realize that caffeine
can have two additional damaging effects on your sleep.
The first comes down to, as you said,
the duration of action.
That caffeine has for most people,
a half-life of what we call about five to six hours.
In other words, after about five to six hours,
50% of that caffeine is still in your system,
which means that caffeine has a quarter-life
of between 10 to 12 hours.
So if you have a cup of coffee, let's say 02:00 p.m.
a quarter of that caffeine
could still be circulating your brain at midnight.
So it would be the equivalent of a 02:00 p.m cup of coffee
is the equivalent of getting into bed
and just before you turn out the light,
you speak a quarter of a cup of Starbucks
and you hope for good night of sleep,
that's probably
not going to happen.
No bueno.
There are differences from one individual to the next.
It comes down to the specific enzyme that degrades caffeine.
Some people have a genetic variant
what we call a polymorphism that has a faster metabolic rate
for the degradation of caffeine other people have slow,
that usually determines I'm a sensitive person.
I'm not sensitive.
But even if you're one of those people
and some people say this to me, look,
I can have an espresso with dinner and I fall asleep fine
and I stay asleep, so no problem.
That's not quite true because even if you fall asleep
and stay asleep,
caffeine can actually decrease the amount
of deep Non-REM sleep that you get.
Can decrease the quality of that deep sleep by up to 20%.
Now for me to drop your deep sleep quality,
I would have to age you by a decade.
Or you could do it with a cup of coffee in the evening,
you know, each and every night.
And the problem is that then,
those people when they wake up the next morning,
they don't remember struggling to fall asleep.
They don't remember waking up,
frequently throughout the night,
so they don't put two and two together,
but now they feel unrefreshed and unrestored by their sleep
because they weren't getting the deep sleep.
And now they find themselves reaching for-
Gotta drink more caffeine.
Three cups of coffee
in the morning and then,
because they may not be able to get to sleep at night,
then they're reaching for sleeping pills.
So it's this sort of, you know,
it's the stimulant in the morning.
It's a sedative in the evening,
and it's a very difficult cycle to break.
So that's caffeine.
Alcohol.
Alcohol is probably the most misunderstood sleep aid
that there is out there.
It's anything but a sleep aid.
And, you've mentioned how your sleep was so disrupted.
First, the alcohol is in a class of drugs
that we call the sedatives.
And sedation is not sleep.
But when we have a couple of drinks in the evening
and we say, gosh, I've just fell asleep like that.
You're mistaking sedation for sleep.
So if I were to show you your electrical patterns
of brainwave activity with and without alcohol,
they're not the same.
It's not naturalistic brainwave activity.
The second problem with alcohol
is that it fragments your sleep
so that you wake up many more times throughout the night.
So not only is your sleep, you know,
going to be poor quality as we'll come on to.
It's also just not going to be consolidate,
it's not that little nice, long duration
of uninterrupted sleep.
Because as your body is processing the alcohol,
the depressant aspect of that drug is wearing off.
And there's a sort of rubber banding similar reaction to it.
So you wake up at two or three in the morning.
So it actually will start to just, as you mentioned there,
it will trigger activation of the fight or flight branch.
So you start to come back online in terms of that
stress related branch of the nervous system.
Also stress related neurochemicals,
we know are starting to get increased as the alcohol
is metabolized.
And that's what causes the fragmentation of your sleep.
The final problem with alcohol is that
it's a very potent suppressor of your REM sleep,
of your dream sleep.
Which we've mentioned before in terms of all its benefits.
And so, you know,
I think that's the reason that alcohol should just be
strongly advised against,
against the nightcap, by medical practitioners.
But I would just say two things, firstly,
with tongue-in-cheek, you know,
you could look at that data and say, well,
then I should just go to the pub in the morning.
And that way the alcohol is out of my system in the evening-
Now we're talking.
But yeah--
Problem with me is
if I go to the pub in the morning,
I'm at the pub at night too.
And so I would never say that
as a healthcare professional.
But what about like just a glass, like,
"Hey, I'm having a glass of wine at dinner."
Yeah, I would love say that,
based on the data that doesn't have an impact,
but if you look at the data even a glass
can have a measurable impact.
But look, the other thing I want to note is this
and I think it's something that I've learned in,
after the book was published.
And I'm embarrassed in the way I was acting before.
I don't wanna be puritanical here, Rich.
You know, I don't,
I don't want to tell people how to live their lives.
I'm just a scientist.
All I want to try and do
and I may be too enthusiastic in doing this
is gift people with the science and the knowledge of sleep.
And then they can make an empowered choice
as to how they want to live their life
if they're trying to optimize their sleep.
So I do want to mention that I am not finger-wagging
and I shouldn't be telling anyone--
I don't think anyone's getting that impression.
I think it's like, look, this is what's going on.
Like make your own, you know, choose accordingly.
But just so everybody knows, let's be clear about
what the science says in terms of how this impacts you.
Yeah, but I think I've been, sometimes overstep the mark.
You're such a gentle guy,
but I also should say like, I love how enthusiastic,
'cause you've talked about this stuff a lot,
but you're so enthusiastic.
Your whole body like lights up when you talk about
this stuff-
Oh my gosh.
It's the, it's the most, I fell in love with, you know,
I fell for sleep like a blind roof, you know,
it was just the most amazing thing
as I was starting to study it.
And it is a love affair that has lasted me 20 years.
And I am still beguiled by
this beautiful thing called sleep at night.
There's so much more still to be learned, right.
Like, you know.
I mean, it's, you know,
I think it's remains
one of the last great scientific mysteries.
I would say though, and the reason that at you're,
someone like me is able to write a book
that's over 130,000 words is because, you know,
we've learned more in the previous 50 years about sleep
than we did in the previous 5,000.
And even just 30 or 40 years ago,
we used to ask the question, what is sleep good for?
And the crass answer was that, well,
we sleep to cure sleepiness,
which is the factual equivalent of saying
we eat to cure hunger.
That tells you nothing about, you know,
the nutritional physiological metabolic benefits of food.
Now 30 or 40 years later, we've had to upend that question.
And we've had to ask,
is there any major organ system in your body
or is there any operation of the mind
that isn't wonderfully enhanced when we get sleep
or demonstrably impaired when we don't get enough?
And the answer seems to be no.
I have to ask you this, every full moon I don't sleep.
And I don't know if it's psychosomatic
or there's some kind of lunar gravitational pole occurring,
but have you looked at this?
We have.
Have you?
Yeah.
Please do tell.
There's some conflicting evidence.
So some reports have found this effect
other reports have not,
and it may be different for men and women even,
some of the reports are saying.
On average people sleep less with a full moon.
So if you ever thought about the term
or what the term means, lunatic.
And it occurred to me when I was doing that work
based on the relationship between sleep
and your emotional health, that you essentially,
your emotional integrity falls apart
when you're not getting sufficient sleep.
You become emotionally unhinged,
you become pendulum like in your emotional irrationality.
It occurred to me,
I wonder if part of the derivative of that term.
We've got all these things, the werewolf-
Well, it goes back forever.
Yeah. Like when the moon's out, people lose their minds.
Right. And you know, I think some of that is due to,
different practices around the celebration
of the moon phases, et cetera.
But I think if you believe some of the reports,
but again, some of the reports have fail
to find this effect, sleep duration decreases.
Why would that be?
There are some theories around that,
which actually I should finish up my tips
and there's just two more of them,
but this is nice because it brings us back to this.
With a full moon,
obviously, as long as it's not a cloudy night,
you get more luminance.
And that light of that luminance
can actually decrease the hormone of melatonin.
And this comes back to what, were I think the,
the fourth out of the five tips, which is darkness,
we are a dark society in this modern era
and we need darkness at night to trigger the release
of this hormone called melatonin.
And melatonin is often called sort of the vampire hormone.
Not because it makes you wanna look longingly
at people's neck lines an bite in,
it's because it comes out at night.
It's the hormone of darkness.
And melatonin helps time, the healthy onset of sleep.
And so the recommendation would be in the last hour
before bed,
don't just stay away from those blue light emitting devices,
try dimming down half the lights in your house.
You would actually be surprised at how sleepy
and soporific that change can be.
And that's why I love the idea of sleeping in a tent
because all of a sudden you are removed from all of that,
you know, polluting electric light even at night.
Now we should reverse engineer that trick during the day.
In the first half of the day,
it's critical to get some exposure to daylight.
You can go outside,
but it doesn't mean that you have to go outside
just being next to a window,
try to get at least 40 minutes of direct sunlight
each and every morning.
And that will really help
because that will then stamp the brakes on melatonin.
It will shut it down and you will feel more alert.
The more alert you feel,
the more healthy sleepiness, the more of that adenosine,
which is the sleep pressure chemical that you will build up
and then the better your sleep will be at night.
So that's sort of darkness
and I think that's perhaps part of the explanation
why the full moon can maybe disrupt our sleep
because it's nowhere near like sunlight,
but it's still a light invasion.
But I wear the eye mask and the whole thing.
I think there's something more mysterious at play.
I don't know, but maybe I'll try taking melatonin.
I know that you've said, you know,
taking melatonin as a matter of course,
it's not a good idea.
It's really for when you're traveling across time zones,
but maybe I'll try it when the next full moon cycle comes.
(indistinct)
Yeah you can try it.
I mean, melatonin, as I mentioned,
it regulates the timing of your sleep,
but it doesn't actually really help
in the generation of sleep.
If you look at people who are not jet lagged
and who are under the age of 50,
melatonin and all of the placebo controlled cities
that we found doesn't really change
the quantity or the quality of your sleep.
Melatonin, you can think of it a little bit like,
the starting official at the 100 meter race.
Melatonin is the thing that will gather all of the,
the races to the start and then begin the great sleep race.
But melatonin doesn't participate in the race itself
that's a whole different set of brain chemicals.
But I would say two things regarding melatonin.
First, if you think that it's working for you,
then the placebo effect is the most reliable effect
in all of pharmacology, with the exception
of probably an adrenaline injection to your heart.
So no harm, no foul there.
The caveat that I would like to add to that secondarily
is, it's over the counter
at least here in the United States,
which means it's not regulated by the FDA.
And in a study that looked at
over 20 different brands of melatonin,
what they found is that based on what it said on the bottle,
relative to what was actually in those melatonin pills,
it was anywhere between 80% less,
or up to 460% more than what it said on the bottle.
So it's a wild West, you don't really know what-
Is there a trusted brand?
Well, I think, you know, firstly,
I should also mention that Melton is,
is still largely a safe compound.
Even in high doses it's concerned from that aspect
is perhaps lower,
but because it's unregulated, what,
one of the things I've been seeing right now, you know,
are melatonin gummies for kids.
And, maybe we'll learn more about melatonin
and it could help kids with sleep problems
or sleep disorders.
But if it's unregulated, you don't know
what does you're giving-
Wouldn't the concern
also be, if you're taking it all the time,
doesn't that signal your body to stop producing it.
That's right.
The regular way.
So that's the other major sort of issue
is that most people are taking too much melatonin.
They're taking usually between five milligrams
up to 10 milligrams.
I would recommend based on the science
somewhere between just 0.5 to three milligrams,
because if you're dosing any higher,
your body has this beautiful network of feedback loops
and it starts to think, well, my goodness, you know,
I don't need to produce melatonin
because I'm getting it every night in very high dose.
I can just shut down my own melatonin production.
So that's the danger.
Just be a little bit mindful.
On the subject of light,
talking about the, the light on a full moon,
I've come to develop a greater appreciation
for the brain's capacity
to process spectrums of light
and how that relates to how we calibrate our internal clock.
Like I had neuroscientist Andrew Huberman here.
Do you know Andrew?
Oh yes from Stamford.
We've never met.
You guy gotta be
(indistinct)
We know of each other
and we should, at some point we should get together
and mind-meld because
I think we'd have a lovely time together.
He's doing some interesting work,
but he talks a lot about how really the eye is,
is the brain.
Like the optic nerve is part of the brain
and the sensitivity of the optic nerve
to all these variations in light spectrum.
He talks about looking at, you know,
at how looking at a sunset, you know,
kind of helps calibrate all of that,
all of these different things.
And I was thinking about that the other day.
'Cause I play this game when I wake up with myself,
when I wake up in the morning.
I open up my eyes, I don't have an alarm clock
and I try guess exactly what time it is.
And it's pretty amazing.
Like I'm generally, I don't always get it right.
But I'm generally like within two minutes
of the precise time.
And I thought is that because my eye knows
the specific light spectrum of what time of day it is,
or is it my internal clock?
Like what is that?
But there is this deep knowing I think that we have
when we are more in nature
where we're attuned to these rhythms.
I think it's a combination of both.
And by the way, his work is just fantastic.
If people, I know you've had him on your show,
just this, he is just a brilliant scientist
and he's so eloquent and beautiful-
He's a very effective communicator.
He knows how to explain things in a way
where people can really understand what he's talking about.
Yeah, he's wonderful.
But so I think it's a combination of those two things.
I think many of us,
even if we've got blackout curtains and stuff,
we're wearing an eye mask, we will wake up
and I think we have some general sense,
but maybe plus or minus an hour in terms of accuracy
that, okay, it's still probably the middle of the night
or hey it kinda feels like late in the morning.
And in part,
that's because you do have an internal 24 hour clock,
but I also think that there's something that we've lost
in terms of our light exposure that you have gained back.
Which is that it's not just that your internal clock,
which may get you, you know,
within one hour plus or minus.
It's not bad at doing that but when you open up your eyes
and you get additional exogenous information,
which is from the outside world
rather than the endogenous clock time
that your 24 hour clock is giving you,
then you shift from plus or minus an hour of accuracy
to maybe plus or minus five minutes.
And so--
yeah, it's fascinating.
I love this.
It's something I,
when I retire maybe I'll look at this
because there's something very strange about sleep and time
that is utterly paradoxical.
And what I mean by this is you can say, okay,
I've got to wake up 'cause I'm going to, you know,
I'm gonna fly out and meet Matt Walker in Berkeley
and we're gonna grab coffee
and I've got to get this early morning flight from LAX.
And you set your alarm for five o'clock in the morning
and guaranteed you will wake up at 04:58.
Right 100%.
How is that possible?
It's crazy.
And it happens
too frequently for it to be just by chance.
So somewhere your brain has this quartz,
like precision of clock counting.
However, there is an absence of time,
particularly in dreaming.
Because all of us have probably had that experience
that our alarm goes off and we were in this strange dream
and then we hit the snooze button and our snooze button
is just two minutes.
And we go back and we go right back into the dream again
and then the snooze button goes off
and you think, hang on a second, I was,
that felt like almost an hour of an experience.
So there is this temporal mismatch
where when we go into the dream state,
we can almost fold and compress time, like a concertina.
It's like inception.
Yeah. And I think it's no big surprise
that Nolan picked up on that,
with the help of maybe some sleep specialists
offering their advice.
We know that you get this, you know,
this dilation I've called it sort of dream dilation
or dream time dilation.
Where-
So what do you,
so what do you make of that?
Like what would be the evolutionary advantage of that?
Well, it may be
that there is no necessarily evolutionary advantage,
but there may be a brain mechanism that explains it.
Because what we know is that memories are replayed
during both deep sleep and REM sleep.
Now, when we are in deep sleep,
memories are actually sped up.
The brain will actually be replaying those memories
anywhere between five to 20 times faster.
But when we go into dream sleep,
the replay is actually much slower.
And so that may be why, if you want to speak about the,
that's usually the one question I,
I look forward to least when I give talks,
someone put the hand up and say, "Is inception possible?"
And my heart just sinks.
I start seeing a spinning top and the music that comes by,
but I think that that's why Nolan
had that beautiful idea that when you descend down
into these different levels of sleep,
you know, a minute of time in the real world could be,
five minutes of time in the dream world.
And then if he gets you to deeper dream states,
then a minute of time in the real world
is two hours or two days or 50 years.
The premise being I'm gonna anchor this memory
or this concept, or this idea in this human's brain
and the way to do that,
how do you do that in an effective way
where it's gonna stay?
And when you, when you think about this in the context of,
of, you know, morphing time constructs,
if you have a dream state in which memories are accelerated,
that's certainly gonna aid
in the development of skill acquisition, right?
Like you're repeating a memory or a behavior,
or just imagine, you're in jujitsu
and you learned a new maneuver or whatever,
and you're replaying that in your mind.
Of course, that's gonna anchor that.
And then the slowing down is almost like a visualization.
Well-
Both of those things
would work in tandem to really,
sort of calcify neural pathways around like a new concept.
Oh, you need to be a scientist Rich.
Would you direct (indistinct).
My mom would be very happy,
if I went to medical school.
No, you're too precious in what you do otherwise.
But so you're absolutely right
that I think what we know is that deep sleep will,
one of its functions is that it will hit the save button
on your memories so that you don't forget.
So deep sleep will future proof that information
within the brain.
And in part it's just, as you said, it's deep sleep.
That's basically scoring the memory trace,
almost etching it, you know, into the,
the glass of the brain.
But then, you know, dream sleep comes along.
And what we've realized is that dream sleep
does something very different from memories.
Sleep is much more intelligent than we ever gave it credit
when it comes to information processing.
Sleep not only strengthens individual memories,
it will intelligently stitch and associate
those new memories together.
And it seemed to be during sleep,
particularly during dream sleep,
when we perform,
it's almost like informational alchemy
or it's like group therapy for memories,
maybe that's a better analogy.
That sleep gathers in all of this information
that you've been learning during the day.
And everyone gets a name badge,
but sleep forces you to go and speak to the people,
not at the front of the room
that you think I've got the most obvious connection with,
it force issues to speak to the people
at the back of the room
that you think you've got no connection with at all.
Now it turns out that you do,
and it's a non-obvious connection,
but it's a potentially powerful one, nonetheless,
because when you start to fuse things together
that shouldn't normally go together,
but offer marked advances in evolutionary fitness,
it sounds like the biological basis of creativity.
And that's where we see dream sleep, providing a benefit.
You wake up the next day with a revised mind wide web
of associations,
and you are capable of dividing solutions
to previously impenetrable problems.
And the reason that you've never been told
to stay awake on a problem.
Sleep on a problem.
But it has a very strange and illusive relationship
with memory.
Like memory doesn't seem to really be required for this.
Like sometimes you will-
The recollection
You remember
some of this stuff and then it fades, but nonetheless,
the brain is doing its job in that state
and you're able to come up with a creative solution
or solve a problem that mystified you the night before.
Yeah. And I have another,
it's probably second only to the idiocy of my idea
that we never evolved sleep,
that we have, you know,
it was from sleep that wakefulness emerged
that we started at the top of the air of the podcast,
the other stupid theory is that in fact,
we remember all of our dreams.
You know, most of us when we wake up,
if we can remember a dream, it's usually very difficult
and different people have different dream recall strengths.
And the harder that we try, the, you know,
unlike the more unlikely it is.
But I think that that's not a problem of memory imprinting.
I think that's a difference in memory science that we call
accessibility versus availability.
I think one, when we wake up in the morning,
we lose the IP address to the memory.
So we can't find it.
So it's availability is prevented,
but I believe it's accessibility, it's still present there,
we just can't.
So it's sorry, it's I got that wrong.
It's availability is still there,
but it's accessibility is prevented.
And the reason I, I think this is a tenable theory,
and I've got some ideas how to test it
is because you can wake up in the morning think,
Oh, I was having this incredible dream
and you just can't bring it back to mind
and you think, okay, it's just gone.
And then two or three days later,
you're walking down the street and you see a sign,
or you're in the shower, you see the shampoo bottle
and all of a sudden there's a cue
that triggers the unleashing of that dream memory.
And it all comes flooding back.
In other words, that memory was there all along
you just didn't have accessibility to a still yet
available and present memory.
Now, if that's true,
what it could mean is that we store all of our dreams.
And the reason I find that sort of hand-waving wacky
and fun philosophically to think about
is we know that memory operates largely
in a non-conscious manner.
You know, you can, for example,
if you're walking up a set of stairs and you, you know,
you got your pad of paper and you've left a drink
on the stairs, you know, you sort of,
you're reaching down to pick it up
that's an immensely complex challenge.
You had to sort of compute the physics
of where your hand was.
You have to know what the weight of that cup was,
this all based on memory.
And it operates low way below the radar of consciousness.
Most memories do.
If that's true that our behavior
is certainly influenced non-consciously
by our memories is what we call implicit memory.
And we remember many of our dreams.
Then all of a sudden it becomes interesting to ask,
how much does our waking life reflect or is shaped by
our stored dreams?
In an unconscious way.
Now, this is getting very Freud in, and I have to say,
I'm not a big advocate of Freud.
I think he, you know,
he did a remarkable service to the science of sleep.
He brought dreams into the world of the mind before it was,
you know, in the Greeks, it was coming from god's, you know,
Hypnos, Somnus, you know, Morpheus.
And then Chinese cultures had an idea
that dreams came from the soul,
but it was Freud who actually placed dreaming squirly
within the mind.
In other words, Freud made dream science,
a domain of brain, of neuroscience.
Now, after that, it all kinda went south, you know,
and I often joke that I think Freud was 50% right
and a 100% wrong.
And so, and it's not--
when it got into
the interpretation aspect.
A testable theory
interpretation.
Exactly. And that's just, and we've demonstrated
that it's why it's no longer embraced
by the scientific community as a scientific hypothesis,
because it's untestable, it has no solid predictions.
And I think it's good to keep in mind that, you know,
there are some reports that at the time Freud
was doing enough cocaine to kill a small horse
when he was coming up with some of that too.
So maybe you want to-
Back to cocaine.
Yeah, I know I will, what is it about me,
I can't seem to get away from it.
So I think I have this enamored theory about dreaming
and it's just not very fundable
so it's hard to get there that the funds.
I mean, I think it's the ultimate unknown terrain
and just unbelievably fascinating,
like the idea that our brain is so complex
and it's performing this mystical dance and computation
while we sleep.
And the extent to which we barely began to understand
what that's all about, I think is just super interesting.
I mean, and you mentioned this very early on
in our taping about dreams.
It is another very strange state,
because last night you and I both
became flagrantly psychotic.
And we did that multiple times throughout the night.
Now, before you dismiss my kind of, you know,
diagnosis of our nighttime psychosis,
I'll give you five good reasons.
Firstly, when we went into dream sleep,
we started to see things which were not there
so we're hallucinating.
Second, we believe things that couldn't possibly be true.
So we're delusional.
Third, we get confused about time, place and person.
So we're suffering from disorientation.
Fourth, we have a wildly fluctuating emotions,
something that psychiatrists call being affectively labile,
and then how wonderful you and I woke up this morning
and we forgot most, if not all of that dream experience-
And we were paralyzed.
As if suffering from amnesia.
We were paralyzed throughout.
Yeah many people don't realize this,
that when you go into dream sleep,
your brain paralyzes your body so the mind can dream safely.
So you don't act out your dreams.
And there is the parts of the brain that actually control
the different stages of sleep,
impart or deep down within the brainstem.
Now, when the brain is ratcheting up,
it's upstairs activation of the brain
for REM sleep, for dreaming,
it sends another signal down along the spinal cord
and it paralyzes what are called
the alpha motor neurons in your spinal cord,
These control all of your voluntary skeletal muscles.
So when you deliberately wanna move your hand,
move your foot, sort of change your mouth, speak, et cetera.
So you all locked in physical incarceration
during REM sleep.
You are imprisoned within your own body.
So when you have that, or I should say,
when I've had these experiences where I'm being chased
or something's happening,
and I feel like I'm stuck in molasses,
or I wanna scream and I'm like,
my wife, Julie will like the next morning,
she'll be like, you are making the weirdest noises
and I'll have some memory that will trigger a memory
like, Oh, I was being,
I was being pursued and I was trying to get away
and I couldn't and I was,
I was screaming out for help,
but I couldn't even make a noise.
And that's exactly why,
you see you're too much of a good scientists.
But would it,
so is sleepwalking then,
a malfunction in that paralytic system
like what's happening when you're sleepwalking.
No. So sleep walking, sleep talking,
they are a group of disorders called parasomnias,
which sort of essentially means just disorders
that happen around sleep, para, meaning around.
Sleep walking and sleep talking
actually don't come from REM sleep.
You would imagine that they do
and it's a very logical thing.
In fact, what happens is that when we are in deep sleep,
for reasons that we don't quite yet understand,
but it may be that there's a jolt of nervous system activity
and all of a sudden your brain races,
or it tries to race from the basement of deep sleep
all the way up to the penthouse of wakefulness
but it gets stuck somewhere in between like the 13th floor,
for example.
And what's strange,
and we can do this in the sleep laboratory
where we've got these electrodes
and what we're seeing outside in terms of the brainwaves
is deep sleep.
But when you look at the camera,
all of a sudden the patient is out the bed and the sort of,
you know, they're sort of moving around.
And so if you wake someone up,
who's having a sleep walking or sleep talking event,
and you say, you know, what was going through your mind?
They usually won't tell you anything.
And the reason is because they're in deep sleep,
but not in dream sleep.
That's so interesting.
Yeah, I have some epic sleepwalking stories
from when I was a kid.
I went out, I got up in the middle of the night
and went outside in the middle of a thunderstorm
and like walked a block away from the house
until my dad discovered what,
and I woke up standing in the middle of the street
in a downpour.
There are some remarkable case studies.
Some of which I discussed in the book
where people have these episodes and some, you know,
some dangerous and some unfortunate things really happen-
But then I just grew out of it.
Like how normal is that?
It's very normal. So the incidents of,
of sleep walking and sleep talking is far higher
when we're kids and most adults will grow out of it.
Not all adults, but most adults will grow out of it.
And it's not really a sleep disorder necessarily.
I think, you know, and again, I'm not a clinician.
And I'm not trying to pretend to be
a sort of a doctor in any means.
But I think the general advice is,
if it's not causing you distress
and it's not putting you in harm's way,
then one may not need to worry about it
if it's sort of infrequent,
but if it is causing you distress
and it is putting you in harm's way,
then you can go see your doctor.
And I should note by the way,
something to on those sort of five tips,
and I should mention walk it out just which is the last one.
None of those tips are really gonna help anyone
who has insomnia or, you know, sleep apnea.
It's like me being, you know, your performance coach.
I can give you all sorts of tips to optimize
your performance.
But if you've got a broken ankle,
none of those tips are going to help you.
We've got to get you to a doctor, treat the broken ankle,
and then we come back to sort of optimizing your sleep.
So the tips I'm giving are just that.
Right, I understand.
But what percentage of people are truly insomniacs
versus people who have habits
that prevent them from getting a good night's sleep
and call themselves insomniacs.
It's actually very difficult to tell
because part of the treatment for insomnia,
which is now no longer sleeping pills,
the first-line treatment
has to be something called Cognitive Behavioral Therapy
for Insomnia or CBTI for short,
one of the things that works towards.
So as you can tell by the name cognitive behavioral,
there is an aspect where we work on the mind
and we work around, your beliefs and your expectations
and your understanding of sleep
that's the cognitive part of CBTI.
The behavioral part is actually asking what behaviors
are you engaging in that are harming your sleep?
And what things are you not doing behaviorally
that can help your sleep?
Alcohol, caffeine, regularity, light, et cetera.
So those do play a role,
but usually it's much more of a combination
of different things with CBTI.
It's a much more extensive than that.
It's just as effective as sleeping pills in the short term,
much more effective in the long-term,
unlike sleeping pills when you start working
with your therapist,
the benefits of CBTI cognitive behavioral therapy
for insomnia last for up to five years,
but for sleeping pills, when you stop using them,
not only do you typically go back
to the bad sleep you are having,
you actually have even worse sleep.
It's called rebound insomnia
caused by these sleep medication.
Yeah. I have friends who are in recovery for,
for Ambien and the stories they tell are just harrowing.
Yeah. It's and you know,
there is a time and a place for those medications.
They're usually recommended for acute short term
significant episodes.
So let's say that you're really struggling with
a trauma or bereavement or something along those lines.
Then in combination with therapy,
they can be advised for short term use.
The problem is most people aren't using them
in a short term use model.
You know, and I, the reason in part I know this is,
I think it took George Lucas about 30 or 40 to a mass,
something like 2 billion in profit
from the Star Wars franchise,
that took Ambien less than 24 months to do that.
That's (indistinct)
So we can't do that with acute use.
So I, again,
sleeping pills have been associated with
high risk of death, as well as cancer.
Do we know that that's causal or not?
No, we don't right now.
And I can make an argument as to why it may not be causal,
but I can also make our scientific argument
as to why it is causal.
We probably won't have a find out
because based on the association between mortality risk
and things such as cancer and sleeping pill use,
it's probably going to be unethical
to do a study where you put people healthy,
people on sleeping pills for several years
because of the risk.
Yeah. No way.
There's no way you could athletically justify that.
No.
We've been going almost three hours.
We have gone--
But I can't let you go.
I do wanna ask you before I let you go.
I know that you work with Google and I'm interested in,
I used to work with Google.
You used, okay.
In that capacity,
were you able to help them implement certain policies?
Like what kind of transpired there
in terms of the work culture that was going on
and the impact that, your work had on that culture?
Yeah. So I was actually working with a,
a part of Google that was called Verily, which is sort of,
that was the Google health arm.
And so-
So it wasn't focused on-
So it wasn't really focused on going into there
and changing the culture.
It was more about sort of developing
either technologies or it was also,
they have some remarkable cities in there that public about,
there's some aspects that I can share,
where they're looking at how things such as sleep
impact different aspects of human health.
So that they're doing wonderful things in trying to augment
things like diabetes, risk, cardiovascular risk.
And so, I think what they realized
is that when you're looking at all of these disease states,
based on everything that we've spoken about
for the past three minutes,
which now is now three hours
and talking about time dilation.
Right. We're having our own inception.
Yeah, we really.
And so-
We are dreaming.
I think I'm gonna wake up and the alarm goes off
and I thought, Oh, I'm so sad.
I thought I was on the Rich Roll podcast.
That's tomorrow.
And so knowing how critical sleep is,
you know, the foundation,
they realized that the hat to be some
component of sleep appreciation within that framework
of everything that they were trying to do.
So I was so fortunate enough to be able to do that.
And I no longer work with them.
I've got a couple of startups that I'm now advising
and working for.
And so that was really, I think the push there,
which was that sleep is the tide that rises
all the other health boats.
And I remember when I was sort of speaking early with them,
I always almost had this analogy where if you think about
a music studio and those recording decks
with all of those dials
and you can sort of mix and just sort of tweak them,
what we're doing in health
is trying to sort of go to individual dials.
We're trying to manipulate cardiovascular health
or change immune health
or change metabolic and diabetes health.
But there's that one sort of dial
all the way over to the left,
that if you move it all the way up,
all of the other dials go up as well.
The master dial.
That's sleep.
Sleep is the Archimedes' lever.
I think if I were to have something,
a single sentence,
I would say that sleep is the single most effective thing
that we can do each day to reset the health of our brain
and our body.
That would be a beautiful place to end this,
but I just realized there's an important thing
we also didn't talk about
that I would like you to touch on quickly.
Yeah, of course.
Which is the,
you talked at the,
at the outset about what happens when you get a flu shot
and you're sleep deprived.
We're still in the midst of this pandemic.
We're slowly emerging out of it,
but can you talk a little bit about
what you've learned about,
sleep, COVID, immunity
and how people should be kind of thinking about how
their relationship with, with the virus?
Yeah. So let me,
I'll speak about sleeping immunity sort of more generally,
and then come on to sleep and COVID.
Because sleep has changed
in at least four different ways because of COVID.
Quantity, quality, timing, and dreaming.
So I'll try to mentally
put those stickies up on my cerebral wall
so I come back to them.
But in terms of sleep and immunity,
there is a very intimate association
between your sleep health and your immune health.
Firstly, what we know
is that individuals who report sleeping
less than seven hours a night
are almost three times more likely to become infected
by the rhinovirus, which is the common cold.
Second we know from a prospective study in,
I think it was well over 30,000 women,
women sleeping five hours or less a night
are more than 60% more likely to develop pneumonia
across a five-year period,
which of course is a critical part
of the COVID mortality equation.
We've also mentioned that statistic about
if you're not getting sleep in the week
before you get your flu shot,
you can't produce the normal antibody response.
Do we know that that's the case for COVID yet?
No we don't.
But we're looking at that.
We also know it's the case for hepatitis A,
hepatitis B vaccination too.
So I think there's an interesting case to be made
that it could make a difference.
We also know that just as we mentioned before,
just one night of short sleep, you know, just four hours,
will drop those critical anticancer fighting cells,
natural killer cells by 70%.
If that's true, then why,
what is sleep doing for our emotional health.
And sleep provides us with that sort of sorry,
not emotional health, for our immune health.
It provides us two different benefits.
Firstly it's during sleep and particularly during deep sleep
where the body will be stimulated to produce
many more of those critical immune factors.
Even better, sleep will actually increase the sensitivity
and the receptivity of your body
to those increased immune factors.
So you wake up the next morning
as a more robust immune individual.
Sleep will restock the weaponry in your immune arsenal.
So on that basis,
I think sleep has become very relevant in this pandemic.
How has sleep changed right now?
Well, as I mentioned, first, the studies show on average,
which may be surprising to some people.
sleep duration has actually increased
somewhere between about 20 to 30 minutes
if you look at the handful of studies
that are published at-
so people aren't commuting.
Not commuting-
They don't have to
the kids to school.
(indistinct) Kids to school.
So that's the first issue.
Now, if you look at that data a bit more closely,
it's not that clean cut or straightforward.
There is a cloud of data of people for whom
sleep has actually become worse.
People have lost their jobs.
People don't know if they will still have their jobs.
People are just, you know, very anxious about the pandemic.
All of those things will decimate sleep of course.
So sleep quantity has changed.
Sleep quality has changed also,
but we also know that sleep timing has changed.
How are you getting that extra sleep?
Well, people are gonna bad a little bit later,
but they're waking up significantly later.
And I think this comes back to our discussion of chronotype.
Now COVID because we don't have to commute and wake up
or do early morning meetings, or get the kids to school,
many people have been able to sleep back in synchrony
with their natural chronotype.
It's revenge of the night owls,
in that way.
And then the final component is that people.
And I think we, we don't yet have enough data,
but there's too many people saying this,
that they were dreaming more
and dreaming more about COVID.
Why would this be?
I think there are two logical explanations.
The first, just as we mentioned before,
the later that you sleep into the morning,
the more you go into that REM sleep bridge phase.
So you're just giving yourself probabilistic chance
statistically of having more dreams.
But I don't think that's the entire explanation.
We also have spoken about this idea that REM sleep
provides this form of emotional first aid,
it's overnight therapy.
In fact, there's an American entrepreneur E. Joseph Cossman
who had this lovely line.
He said that the best bridge between despair and hope
is a good night of sleep.
And I think when we're going through these, you know,
difficult emotionally upheaval time of a pandemic,
no wonder the brain is trying to self-medicate it, you know,
this emotional situation with the thing that it knows
provides a nocturnal soothing balm,
which is this thing called REM sleep and dreaming.
I think that's probably another explanation as to why
we're not just dreaming more,
but we're dreaming about the pandemic itself.
Trying to make sense of it, trying to process it,
trying to figure out a way
to kind of have a healthier relationship with it.
That's right.
It just, you know,
sleep divorces some of the emotion from the memory
so that you come back the next day
and you feel better about those emotional experiences,
because sleep has essentially stripped
the bitter emotional rind from the informational orange.
So it's not as though you wake up the next day
and you don't remember that emotional experience you do,
but it it's no longer as emotional itself.
And so it's not time that heals all wounds,
it's time during sleep and specifically dream sleep
that provides emotional convalescence.
It would be on,
on the immunity subject,
it would be interesting to do an evaluation of,
of people that got COVID,
how severe their case of COVID was,
and track that onto their sleep habits and patterns.
People are doing that.
And we're looking at that.
We're also looking at when you get vaccinated,
what are the consequences?
Some people are describing disruptions to their sleep,
usually what will happen,
is that you will have some degree of fever.
When you go into fever
that increases your core body temperature.
When your body temperature increases,
you're not going to get good sleep.
There are some devices that are now,
and I worthy ordering as full sort of disclosure.
I advise the company,
so take anything I say with a grain of salt,
but I was wearing the device for two,
I've worn just about every sleep tracking device.
And it was just the one that for me, you know,
was a sticky device and I liked it.
So I was wearing it for two years
before I decided to join the company,
but they have a fascinating model.
What they've been able to find because the oura ring,
unlike many of these other sort of devices,
it tracks temperature.
And what they were finding is that in some people who
then went on a day later or two days later
to find out that they tested positive for COVID,
there was this spike-
Spike in temperature.
In their relative temperature.
And so, we're now starting to explore this idea
that it could be a useful diagnostic tool-
A (indistinct)
Preemptive.
Exactly.
I've got the whoop on and they manage that,
not through temperature, but through metabolic rate.
And they have some interesting science on that as well.
So it's cool how these wearables are sort of developing
and how the technology is evolving.
It's funny, isn't it?
But I think we're only
beginning to understand like the significance
that they can play.
Yeah, exactly.
I think I mentioned this invasion of technology
into the bedroom and it has been a deleterious force,
but perhaps unlike some other sort of sleep scientists,
I'm not puritanical about technology.
that genie is out the bottle and it's not going back in
any time soon.
So if you want to rail against it, you'll lose.
But what we're now seeing is this beautiful sort of cycle
where technology is starting
to solve some of the problems of technology.
And it's like that light in the matrix,
you know, programs hacking programs.
And it's technology starting to hack the ills of technology.
So I do think that wearable technology
has a part to play in a place
in our subsequent future health,
this idea of personalized medicine.
And for me, I'm interested in personalized sleep medicine
that's why I'm trying to sort of develop
some of these companies.
But I also think we need to be a little bit careful.
There's now something called Orthosomnia
which is a sleep disorder
caused by obsessive sleep tracking,
where you become so anxious.
And so now it seems to be maybe 10 to 15% of the people
who are using these suffer from,
Oh, by the way, Orthosomnia comes from,
Ortho means straighten in medicine.
If we've heard of orthopedics, orthodontics,
straightened teeth, straightened bones.
Here, it's about people getting too concerned
about getting their sleep straight.
Orthosomnia.
I mean 100%.
I mean, I think they're just tools.
It's about your relationship-
That's right.
But if you become obsessive about them,
they work across purposes with their intent.
Like I know there are certain days
where I'm not sure I really wanna look at
whatever the whoop score is because-
Priority.
Like I got stuck to do.
And if it says like I'm not ready for it,
that's gonna screw me up.
I just would rather, I'll check it later.
I use them as I think they're,
for me my relationship to them is more in the macro.
Like I can look at trends over time.
Exactly.
Or I play a game
where I wake up in the morning and I'll think,
I'm pretty sure here's where I'm at.
And then I'll check it and that helps me calibrate
my intuition around these things.
And the more intuitive you are about them,
the less reliance upon them, I think you become,
but you have to hold them a little bit lightly.
I love that. I think that's a,
it's such a beautiful way of thinking about it.
Often what I will say to people when the they say,
look, I had this really bad night of sleep
and I don't wanna look at my ring.
Firstly, everyone has a bad night of sleep,
don't worry about it, it's not the end of the world.
The second thing, when it comes to trackers of any kind
and particularly with sleep,
follow weekly or monthly trendlines,
don't follow nightly headlines,
don't worry about those things.
And I think the reason
I believe sleep tracking is perhaps a little bit different
than other aspects of health wearable tracking.
When I go to the gym,
I kind of know if I got a good workout in or if I didn't
and when I be eating throughout the day,
I know if I've been eating clean and in a healthy way,
or if I haven't.
You don't wanna score on that.
And I think I probably will know it
and some days I'm ashamed of it,
but what's interesting about sleep,
is that for the most part, it's a non-conscious process.
And so if I were to ask you, you know,
Rich last night, how did you sleep?
You can tell me,
but if I said to you Rich,
how did you sleep last Tuesday?
By yourself you probably don't know.
But that's where I think the power
of some of this technology,
it can identify trends and patterns.
And if we can start to measure those and then intervene
to give people useful tips as to what they should do
in a personalized manner,
because everyone is sleeping poorly for different reasons.
That's really where we unleash the power of these things.
Matt Walker, we gotta end this thing.
So great talking to you.
Will you come back and talk to me again sometime?
If would have me and if your listeners-
Oh 100%.
Don't lose the will to live
because of my inane voice, I would be delighted-
It's unbelievable.
To come back.
You are a gift my friend,
the work that you're doing, I think is super important.
It's a privilege and an honor
to help amplify it a little bit.
So I really appreciate what you do.
It's a great act of service to humankind
so thank you for that
and thank you for spending the afternoon with me.
I say exactly the same thing back to you,
based on what you're doing.
Your honesty and your vulnerability of story
has impacted people I know,
and what you're doing with this movement around this podcast
and empowering people with mind, body,
guidance and information, I think is fundamentally critical.
So you are a gift.
And now I anoint you as a sleep ambassador as well.
So Rich, thank you so much.
Now the pressure.
I'll have a terrible night of sleep tonight.
Just call me, put me on speed dial, I'll help you.
I'm gonna call you every night, am I doing this right?
Yeah, don't worry I will be right there for you.
Thank you so much for having me.
Thank you.
You could find and learn about Matthew
at the sleepdiplomat.com.
Yes, sleepdiplomat, or if you want,
you can read the book, which is called "Why We Sleep."
You don't have to read the book,
you just have to buy it as what the publishers tell me you.
No, you gotta read it. But-
Trust me.
Just buy a used copy-
The book changed my life.
I'm not interested in monetary stuff,
but if you're able,
or if you're interested in learning more about sleep,
the book is a good way to do it.
Good.
Well, let's, let's do this again sometime.
I hope so.
All right.
Thank you Rich.
Peace.